ah en passant par le speechess ou les
title Tuesday
chess.com/aventure tous les plus grands
tournois d'échec il se déroulent en
présentiel ou en ligne vivez comprenez
en direct les parties des meilleurs
joueurs de la planète avec les
commentaires en français de nos experts
notre moteur d'analyse l'explorateur
d'ouverture et les tables bases
retrouvez toutes les infos essentielles
comme le programme les horaires des
rondes les prix les résultats des
comptes rendus quotidien les bio des
joueurs les règles des partages et plus
encore vous pouvez même participer à la
compétition en pronostiquant les
résultats pour tenter de gagner des
abonnements premium alors rendez-vous
dès maintenant sur Chess.com stash
events ou c'est bien sur le site
internet que sur nos applications iOS et
Android pour vivre votre passion comme
nulle part ailleurs
[Musique]
bon bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce
dernier jour du tournoi rapide
évidemment ensuite nous aurons deux
jours de Blitz et la grande nouvelle
c'est ça la grande nouvelle c'est Maxime
Vacher la grave qui est en tête ah au
début de cette dernière journée qui sera
palpitante tout simplement elle sera
énorme j'espère que vous êtes chaud en
chute très très chaud pour suivre Maxime
va chier La Grave déjà dans cette
première partie j'ai pas update mais
c'est pas grave on va le faire en direct
contre qui joue dans cette 37 il joue
face à harjoon
Eric ETI avec les Noirs le jeune joueur
indien on aura aussi on va évidemment
rajabov
cookehuk Abdou Sator mais la partie qui
nous intéresse le plus c'est évidemment
celle de Maxime et évidemment celle de
Raja bof qui a mis point derrière on le
voit ici les autres sont quand même
assez distancé donc ça se jouera entre
ces deux joueurs
on va regarder on est en place
normalement
pour tout suivre voilà on a le liveboard
comme d'habitude on a les chéquier on a
tout on est prêt il ne manque plus que
les coups on est du bon côté on a les
Noirs face à irigaty
très très agressif oui tout à fait deux
fois les Noirs aujourd'hui il a les
Noirs dans la dernière ronde contre
rajabo je vais regarder à la 8e ronde
qui c'est qui lui reste à jouer qui
c'est qu'il lui reste à jouer qui c'est
qui lui reste à jouer et bien je ne sais
plus je vais regarder il nous restera
déjà bof à la dernière irigaty
maintenant et il lui reste à Maxime va
chez Lagrave il lui reste à la conduite
à Krishna avec les Blancs donc faudra
mettre un point peut-être ou peut-être
mais dans un point tout de suite parce
que
Erik ezi ça va être une partie chaude il
envoie tout art-jun très très beau
joueur à regarder donc on va voir une
partie
magnifique on est répertoire de Maxime
c'est des c'est des siciliennes des
naydorf
donc en général ça donne de ça donne des
belles parties hier il a été impérial
tout simplement très dominateur jouant
vite mais pas trop très très bon il a
été incroyable hier il nous a fait une
Master Class le premier jour c'était
plus plus en premier jour vous voyez où
il y avait des hauts et des bas mais
alors là la deuxième journée a été
magnifique
si il continue sans on va pas évidemment
on va pas le jings mais s'il continue
comme hier bon ben c'est bon c'est pour
nous donc voilà c'est tout ce qu'on lui
souhaite de jouer aussi bien qu'hier
c'est tout ce qu'on nous souhaite salut
à tous dans tous les chats où vous soyez
sur twitch YouTube voilà on sera là
encore deux jours il y a le temps de
Blitz ensuite et on sait
on sait à quel point il est fort en bide
aussi ouh là 4 5 énorme surprise et une
pétrole
une pétrole de mvl et bien ça joue un
peu plus solide et cette variante avec
des 4 donc je vous rappelle que ici sur
ma droite c'est l'échiquier ou je vous
montre des choses et à gauche vous avez
les chéquier vous pouvez voir les live
les coûts vous pouvez c'est toujours le
liveboard donc c'est à dire les coûts en
direct et vous pouvez tout voir et on a
une pétrole donc le coup principal ici
c'est qu'elle prend un sac mais il y a
une petite mode autour de D4 caille
prend le cas joué par Maxime dépend le 5
une des ventes principales fous des
trois et l'autre coup qui a été joué
notamment par Magnus Carlson dans son
match champion du monde face à
face à Yann les pomyachi puis on prend
le 5 D5 kbdo Dame des 7 le coup de
Fabiano carolawana qui est un expert de
la pétrole et Kate jouait très
rapidement par Erika easy qui est pas du
tout surpris par le choix de Maxime
apparemment est-ce que c'est l'influence
de Jules Moussard qui joue la pétrole
aussi peut-être
possible probable
on va voir cahier des 4 qui a un coup
assez rare je crois je sais plus trop
donc Dame des 7 quelle idée de Dame des
7 c'est vrai que c'est bizarre
comme coup mais
on évite les finales fossettes on va
prendre en 4 et prise 4 et dame prend
des 8
et c'est vrai qu'on rétrogé de reprendre
du Fou le cas il va venir là ça ici en
G5 même et ça peut être désagréable
tandis que dans cette ligne là en fait
on prépare la finale et c'est vrai
qu'elle prend maintenant on fait pion
prend et sur dame prend on peut
reprendre une pièce par exemple du
cavalier et attaquer directement le pion
en E5 donc c'est ça l'idée principale
cahier Descartes joué par Erica me
demandait pas l'idée j'en ai aucune idée
peut-être installer un relais de
cavaliers je sais pas je sais pas ce que
c'est faut analyser franchement je
connais pas très bien cette ligne et
dame 7 jouer alors ça c'est quand même
assez improbable peut-être que l'idée
c'est empêché faussette il y aura
peut-être 6 et surpuis on prend vous
voyez qu'elle prend puis on prend la
tête d'un H5 dame 5 ça a l'air assez
dangereux ou sous ces quatre même
ça peut être dangereux donc il est 4
probablement menace aussi c'est pour ça
qu'il joue dame 7 cailles de F3 kd7
attaque le Pione 5 et ib5 mais ça joue
très rapidement donc les deux les deux
les deux joueurs qui semblent être dans
leur prépa Maxime qui prend un petit peu
son temps juste sur le nouveau son
maximum dans on a déjà dit que c'était
Laurent Blanc
le
le nouveau coach de mvl
qui est B5 on attaque le pion on attaque
le pion je vais commencer depuis le
public quand ce quand
quand le rythme s'accélère et qu'on a
envie de voir en grand
kibé 5 et kb6 défendant le pion et
défendant le pion mais c'est pas mal de
tout défendre en un seul coup
et il continue à jouer vite il joue fous
des trois ergy ok ok ok pour avoir joué
reggae easy en Top 16 l'année dernière
il est
et alors il est c'est impossible de
deviner rien que son premier coup il
joue un peu de tout il essaie vraiment
de cibler son adversaire et donc
typiquement
maxime a essayé de cibler sur une nights
c'est à peu près évident Maxime qui joue
une pétrole si il avait joué
quelques-unes et en plus vu la situation
du tournoi bien c'est quand même un
choix solide
2 sur 3 aujourd'hui admettons une nulle
avec les Noirs dans la première une
victoire contre avec les chiens et une
nulle dans la dernière bah ça lui
garantit une victoire dans le tournoi
c'est sûr
donc intéressant comme choix j'aime bien
alors fouder trois fougères
pas trop ça mais on prépare aussi
peut-être le grand rock je suppose que
petit rock va arriver quoi d'autre
c'est pas très clair en tout cas
alors petit rock on peut pas faire grand
rock tout de suite pourquoi parce que il
y a le pion à donc on doit faire un
petit coup d'avoir peut-être un coup de
A6 pour voir
c'est pas c'est pas qu'il est en train
de Maxime les rumeurs disent Laurent
Blanc mais pas sûr
pas sûr fougère petit rock et assise
jouer ok c'est très logique et
clairement Maxime qui se prépare à faire
un grand rock alors vous voyez il joue à
Petrov il joue à petroche chaude quand
même c'est si je crois que c'était pas
bon pourquoi c'était pas bon C6 à cause
de fous prends le 4 le petit coin
intermédiaire et surpuis on prend il y a
des six échec ça ne va pas du tout et si
on fait pion prend B5 et bien regardez
cette structure de pion elle est quand
même pas terrible on peut revenir tout
simplement
et ça ne va pas c'est pour ça qu'il
décide de faire assis à la place de C6
donc à 6 maintenant il faut bouger ce
cavalier ça c'est à peu près clair donc
on peut faire ça on peut faire ça
ça y est assez thématique alors la
structure est détruite mais on joue sur
l'avantage de développement sur la
colonne B qui s'est ouverte sur un
éventuel grand rock des Noirs donc c'est
intéressant aussi c'est pour ça qu'il
réfléchit et qu'il hésite entre cavalier
des quatre et cavalier C3 clairement
quel est le meilleur je n'en sais rien
car ça y est je suis soupçonné je suis
soupçonné par bapou du 69 qui dit tu es
quand même très sur défensif pour
quelqu'un qui dépasse au grand maximum
c'est beau c'est beau j'adore les
théories du complot c'est mes préférés
alors
comment ça marche cette histoire
peut-être Kylie des quatre après le
cavalier a pas tellement de cases
peut-être c'est 5 oui on a un beau
centre quand même déjà je vois pas
comment sauver le cavalier si on fait
cavalier 2 bon ben on va on peut se
faire doubler les pions
on va être obligé de prendre là mais je
vais reprendre je vais encore attaquer
une pièce ça va pas aller
et donc
je sais pas trop comment on fait ici
grillade ouais j'ai j'ai 07 grillades on
lance des rumeurs Laurent Blanc
pourquoi tous mystère sur la seconde en
bas c'est Maxime qui a pas voulu le
le dire voilà bon après moi je pense que
ça change pas grand chose de le savoir
ou pas il veut pas le dire c'est comme
ça
c'est son droit
c'est son droit le plus strict
on va voir ce que fait erikazy il hésite
qui est C3 je serais plutôt tenté par
kays C3
et comment ça se passe
ouais ouais ça intéressant de venir voir
parce que non seulement on peut
apprendre
déjà vous pouvez réfléchir au coup là
qu'est-ce que vous joueriez vous voilà
déjà pourquoi c'est intéressant parce
que qu'est-ce que vous auriez exactement
et
[Musique]
en plus
il y a aussi quand même
on a envie de connaître le résultat
voilà il y a quand même une certaine
adrénaline à regarder un match à être en
plus il y a là il y a Maxime donc on est
quand même
on est quand même ouais on est parti
prenante quoi et il se lève Maxime va
chez Lagrave ça y est la promenade
commence
et ouais mvl premier on n'arrête pas de
me demander la 4e Miss sur 6 il est
premier de ce tournoi et oui excellent
choix Laurent Blanc il a une grande
marge de progression en 4x4 2 4 3 3 ou
Maxime ça serait plutôt un trois
trois
un trois voilà trois trois trois et
trois attaquants un milieu offensif
[Musique]
voilà donc vous pouvez vous voyez vous
pouvez réfléchir pendant que je raconte
des bêtises
alors assises tempo ah on n'est pas
obligé de prendre jolie jolie de la part
de Maxime c'était vu à l'avance quand
parce que qu'elle prend et à ce
vis-à-vis qui est très méchant on
gagnera une pièce donc ça ne va pas du
tout
vous me dites s'il y a trop de bruit
derrière moi mais je crois que ça va
je crois que ça va
grand rock et maintenant il va falloir
se bouger cette dame de vis-à-vis
peut-être dame 2 mais ouverture plutôt
réussie de la part de Maxime qu'est-ce
qu'il a joué il a joué tout roule 1 ok
il veut menace et il prend puis on prend
et tu reprends le 4 comment faire en
général on n'a pas envie de lâcher cette
avant-poste un très beau cavalier on n'a
pas envie de prendre en C3 ça c'est
clair on a envie de faire en sorte que
ça soit pas obligatoire Maxime connaît
tout ça
ouais j'ouvre la fenêtre non il y a pas
les travaux il y a pas les travaux là
ils font ils font une pause dans le BTP
mais ils vont reprendre ce matin très
tôt là il faisait mais là il faut une
petite pause petite pause de 11 heures à
16h ça part faire de mal quand il fait
chaud
on espère on espère que la pause de 11
heures à 16h on en sait rien
j'avais vu une question combien de temps
j'ai travaillé pour l'anus car c'est 10
ans 10 ans mon cher ami et oui 5 matchs
de championnat du monde
et ouais 10 ans
quelque chose fait beaucoup hein trop
long
alors comment on fait on peut jouer ça
aussi j'aime pas prendre honnêtement ça
ouvre à 4 à 5 tours bien j'aime pas du
tout je pense que Maxime non plus il va
pas aimer
mais la jauge déjà préfère les Noirs ce
qui est un peu surprenant
pour mes yeux de
pour mes yeux débutants dans la pétrole
peut-être prises et cavaliers à 4 temps
empêche tout contre jeu attaque le pion
c'est trois c'est une gaffe gaffe du
français gaffe du joueur français
comment ça marche fouger 5 ouh là là
faut que j'ai 5 peut faire mal et sur
foo.fr
et on a quand même gagné une qualité
alors il y a un peu de jeu il y a un
pion certes mais ça devrait pas être
assez
donc c'est pas bon ouais le problème
c'est que quand on fait cahier prend C3
B prend C3 et bien il y a fougé 5 qui
menace derrière donc ça ne va pas
ouais alors à plein à temps plein sous
pas faille à temps plein toute l'année
on avait Peter et Nielsen et moi-même et
pour les machins pas du monde ça sera
forcé alors il y a il y a eu du passage
du beau monde mais on était de 3 à 5
donc il y a eu du Hammer il y a eu du
double évidemment du vin de Forest du
grand déluge du gustaveson
Adams
Eliano beaucoup beaucoup de joueurs je
n'ai jamais compris pourquoi ils sont
tous fait virer pas moi
toujours un mystère qui reste entier
jamais compris
mais bon c'est comme ça la chance
c'est quoi le coup je n'en sais rien
salut robinside du mvl effectivement oh
là là stoon tu as complètement raison
excuse-moi sound évidemment mvl a été
une guest star en 2016 à l'époque il
était numéro deux mondial et était
secondaire de Magnus Carson pour son
match contre caryakin j'allais avec mon
petit ordinateur chez Maxime pour
recueillir ses impressions
et oui et je notais je notais sur mon
petit ordi maxi il dit que l'espagnoles
ouverte c'est chaud pour les Noirs quand
même le Marshall il préfère la
berlinoise il dit que c'est solide la
Grenelle il adore la neige d'or non
parlons pas et il faut jouer E4 avec les
Blancs voilà à peu près
c'est vrai Magnus a déclaré que j'étais
resté pour mon humour non pour mon ouais
humour
comment dire
social skills
voilà mon
côté social voilà
il joue pas la Sicilienne mais il est en
tête du tournoi et c'est un choix de
raison
et F5 vous voyez je vous l'avais dit et
oui bien sûr
on
renforce le cavalier en E4 si on peut le
garder on le garde et sur puis on prend
F6 on va simplement faire puis on prend
et regarder on a ouvert la colonne g et
petite tactique regardez la petite
tactique on se dit on fait un pion et
bien pas du tout d'un coup prend on joue
sur ce clouage
et ça gagne pour les Noirs donc on peut
pas prendre le pion et ensuite on va
jouer F5 on va jouer le tour G8 voir
beaucoup de jeux donc est-ce qu'on peut
vraiment prendre en passant avec les
Blancs je crois pas
ouais il est temps
il est temps
ouais
mvl ouais mais c'est intéressant moi
j'ai vu la la rapidité avec laquelle mvl
arrivée au conclusion c'était assez
impressionnant c'était très
impressionnant de voir Maxime travailler
et faire les choses rapidement on sent
la différence de de classe quand même
numéro de mondiale il était numéro
demandé à l'époque hein donc c'était
quand même c'est un peu risqué de Magnus
c'est toujours ce qu'a fait Magnus
c'est-à-dire on gagne le match et après
on voit ce qui se passe parce que
inviter le numéro de mondial c'est un
peu invité le loup dans la bergerie
c'est-à-dire qu'il voit exactement
comment ça se passe ça peut l'aider pour
plus tard s'il y a un match donc voilà
c'est un choix un petit peu risqué bon
finalement malheureusement
il y a jamais eu ce match entre mvl et
Magnus on est passé près en 2021 2020
c'est toi continuer alors Evelyne
effectivement moi je refais l'histoire
je récupère
s'il te doit continuer en 2020
sentez bien parti un épaule toussé il
était malade
Maxime venait faire une masterclass
contre les pots il était bien solide
mais il y a eu cette interruption d'un
an qui lui a pas qui a pas réussi à
Maximin clairement donc le grand
bénéficiaire a été il y a des premiers
ensuite la pause covid a fait mal mais
d'un autre côté il a été aussi qualifié
grâce au covid parce que Raja bof a
déclaré forfait à cause du covid
bref voilà c'est comme ça
ce match a pas eu lieu il aurait été
mérité pour Maxime et voilà et peut-être
à ce moment-là ma nu soit regretté de
l'avoir invité en 2016 ou pas on ne sait
pas
on saura jamais en fait en tout cas sur
image un peu du monde clairement
Magnus n'a pas avoir de regret vu qu'il
a gagné il a gagné tous ses matchs il a
pas réussi à faire changer la formule
mais bon
et salut à
qui quitte notre ami Maxime la garde
l'autre Maxime small Maxime
le grand Maxime Le maxime a un seul nom
on sait pas comment on sait plus comment
l'appeler
le Maxime quiral il râle beaucoup au
ping-pong et oui ce qui perd
et donc ça fait beaucoup de
handsome Maxime ah ouais c'est ça
small Maxime à l'époque il était appelé
dans mon équipe à Clichy quand vous êtes
en coéquipier avec Maxime va chez
Lagrave c'est la coque qu'il appelait
comme ça small Maxime parce que c'est
vrai qu'il était à l'époque c'est pas
petit pasta mais c'est vrai qu'il était
quand même moins il y avait énormément
d'écart entre entre lui et Maxime Vacher
La Grave bon il y a toujours un petit
écart mais qui s'est quand même le gap
c'est quand même largement
restreint disons que voilà Maxime à
l'époque devait avoir je sais plus 2500
un peu moins de 2500 peut-être je sais
pas ces années que tu choisis
c'est un jeune joueur plan à venir
alors que maintenant c'est un grand
maître expérimenté
F5 bien joué de la part de mvl qui se
balade et qui est déjà beaucoup mieux
sur la jauge et oui ce cavalier en 4
quand on peut le laisser c'est une très
très mauvaise nouvelle pour les blancs
et je sais pas ce qu'on joue du tout
avec les Blancs c'est pour ça que je
parle d'autre chose
alors on regarde ce qu'on suit Maxime en
train de se balader et on le voit se
balader regardez on la prod la pro
dotope hop on le voit passer là-bas oh
là là regardez
parlons BTP en regardez c'est pas beau
ça
parlons BTP ça recommence un petit peu
nos amis du BTP il travaille entre midi
et deux non mais bon non 11h47 faut me
dire c'est pas encore fait
passe sur toutes les cames
non mais disons que soyons honnête c'est
de 2500 c'est minable pour les super
fort non pas du tout c'est juste que
Maxime Lagarde était jeune à l'époque et
donc voilà bon clairement sur une
sur une enfin il est toujours jeune
d'ailleurs mais je ne commande en tout
cas mais en tout cas sur une belle
courbe de progression une courbe de
progression qui est en général avec
l'âge
comme ça
c'est de quoi je parle
et oui Maxime ma chérie grave premier
Catherine mission si c'est une très très
belle position avec un gars qui passent
énormément de temps et Maxime qui prend
ces 6 minutes d'avance il les a il les a
toujours hein ça c'est normal c'est
toujours ces 6 minutes
6 minutes c'est comme ça il est en tête
il est très bien il a cavalière 4 donc
ça va être très compliqué pour les
blancs de se dépatouiller
parce que on peut pas vraiment prendre
peut-être qui va il va être obligé de
prendre en passant mais alors bonne
chance sur dame 2 je fais alors soit je
j'analyse ton G1 peut-être 5 simplement
5 on a tout ça regardez comment ça va
aller vite cette attaque avec le roi ici
tandis que là-bas il se passerait un à
quatre à cinq bon ben certes ben je
bougerai mon cavalier donc ça sera pas
grand chose
et il a joué le prime F6 en passant puis
on prend F6 va être joué au bled c'est
par Maxime qui s'assoit à peine et qui
joue son coup tout de suite qui en met
même pas sa chaise il est déjà prêt à
retourner se balader
et le second Maxime c'est Diniz ah ouais
c'est pas mal ça c'est un rêve je sais
pas les c'est pas les plus jeunes qui
ont un rêve
allez
faut 3 jouer
menace clairement faut prendre ici il
essaie de faire quelque chose oulala
flèche là a perdu de sang ouh là
j'arrive plus à faire les flèches ça y
est c'est l'émotion
faut prendre ici menace je suppose
mais alors qu'est-ce que ça a l'air
mauvais pour irgaliser là je sais pas
est-ce que je peux faire un truc comme
ça
voilà je pars à vie non pas par avis on
a mieux que ça
est-ce que ça c'est un coup ça ça va
être un peu trop les pions devant le roi
on n'aime pas
ça pas vraiment un coup ça serait
vraiment très désirable pour faire
cavalier 5 mais il prend des cinq et
c'est un problème on perd un pion donc
faut prendre ici c'est une micro menace
est-ce que c'est une vraie menace hein
est-ce que je peux faire F5 ici
F5 ah la jauge j'aime bien et surtout
prends mes 6 puis on prend V6 on va
sortir comme ça faut que j'ai 7 tours G8
et ça a l'air quand même pas mal pour
les Noirs je sais pas ce que vous en
pensez
alors
j'aime bien F5 moi est-ce que ton G8 est
jouable
pas du tout
parce qu'il y a une menace quand même il
y a probant une menace ouais ça ça doit
être une menace ouais non ça a pas tu
reprends et tu reprends et maintenant la
combinaison que je vous montre tout à
l'heure avec dam prend un 4 fou prend un
quatre tours prend des Hamat ne marche
plus à cause de la tour qui protège donc
le coup de développement était très
utile parce que beaucoup de
développement non seulement ça fait
jouer vos pièces mais en plus ça lie les
tours qui peuvent jouer donc ça fait
jouer en fait le coup de fou 3 fait
jouer ce fou mais il fait aussi
participer cette tour indirectement en
protégeant la dame et on voit que dans
certaines variantes ça peut marcher donc
F5 est vraiment semble être le coup
j'aime bien F5
est-ce que je peux faire non ok prends
ces trois on veut pas le faire on a tout
fait pour pas le faire donc on va pas le
faire
je vois bien F5 si vous avez d'autres
coups n'hésitez pas à les proposer
en fin de choses si je joue pas une
berlinoise
Maxime il joue une pétrole mais c'est la
pétrole quand les blancs cherchent un
peu ça peut ça peut vite vriller
Mb4 j'aime bien ouais je regardais aussi
pour attaquer B2
j'aime pas peut-être ça simplement
encore une fois il y a un problème sur
ça
ça va pas
donc Maxime qui prend son temps c'est
bien il en a à revendre du temps
je vois pas d'autres c'est 5 et
peut-être non c'est 5 mois ça allait pas
donc j'ai 8 va pas marcher on a déjà
regardé
ouais on a déjà regardé 8 je crois que
le coup va être va être F5 honnêtement
il est en train de vérifier mais c'est
tellement
qui est ces quatre on a déjà regardé
ah non j'ai pas regardé c'est 4 j'ai
pensé mais j'ai pas regardé que ces
quatre intéressants effectivement
est-ce que je peux ouais c'est compliqué
peut-être prise foulard
on prend là-bas
je prends ici tout simplement pardon
pardon pardon pardon et Adam en l'air je
raconte n'importe quoi et ces quatre
intéressants à mon avis ça joue un truc
F5 ouais c'est ça c'est ça son
hésitation
non quand tu es secondaire ça ça dépend
du deal
ça c'est comme tout super fight qui
demande quand tu es secondaire
ça m'est arrivé de jouer contre Magnus
quand j'étais
son second an plein de fois même hein
plein de fois 4 fois quoi et oui donc
non on savait pas du deal qu'on a hein
en l'occurrence moi rien ne m'empêcher
de jouer conduire même de le battre ce
qui m'empêchait de le battre c'est le
mon niveau de jeu
c'est ça le problème
donc il y a une fameuse vidéo vous
pouvez voir au championnat du monde de
Blitz où il joue E4 quand elle est F6 E5
kg 8 donc il revient avec son cavalier
vous pouvez la voir et il a joué quoi
comme prévu
comme prévu ces quatre étaient aussi
très intéressant il faut avouer mais F5
est logique pour cimenter vraiment ce
cavalier en E4 être sûr qu'il se passe
plus jamais rien alors si fouger 5 et ne
tactique qui est intéressant on joue sur
le clouage aussi comme tout à l'heure
nous on jouait sur le coupage j'ai
l'impression mesdames prends G5 et
prends G5 faut calculer il faut prendre
un
j'ai l'impression que globalement ça va
perdre du matériel ça pour les blancs si
cavalier FC la fourchette on a quand
même une pièce de moins donc a priori je
vais reculer comme ça et sur qui prend
ensuite le cavalier est pris au piège
F5 jouer
et donc que va faire ça y est il est
reparti marché
il y a partir marché on le voit là il
est quand même il est incroyable Maxime
là
faut qu'il fasse attention hein parce
qu'il a montré parfois Maxime un petit
peu trop de
s'empresse un petit peu et tout ça même
s'il a l'air très tranquille sur tournoi
mais là il marche beaucoup
il marche beaucoup il est où là on voit
même plus là allez même plus il est dans
le public ou quoi
il est là la partie de Raja bof aussi
bon on va regarder regga easy qui suit
pendant ce temps F5 on veut faire fouger
7 tours G8 mais attention à pas jouer
trop vite
attention exactement attention avec
cette confiance
complètement complètement d'accord
[Musique]
mais n'hésitez pas à vous abonner à nos
chaînes surtout
et puis comme vous voulez à tout
c'est gratuit en tout cas pour ce qui
est du pouce et ça permet de vous avoir
d'avoir un petit rappel c'est ça le truc
on a un on a un rappel c'est-à-dire
qu'on a un petit un petit message un
petit mail qui dit
ah il y a un bel qui joue là
qui ça va
feux de ouais mais le problème de foot 2
c'est que c'est lent je peux jouer vite
j'ai 7 par exemple c'est tellement
confort pour les noirs
pas du tout
mais c'est un peu bizarre peut-être vous
prend et qu'elle prend des cinq
mais faut deux est quand même trop
passif là et il y a complètement raté
son ouverture c'est vraiment un désastre
donc là on menace ça et ça c'est ça
peut-être tourgé 8 tout simplement la
tour j'ai eu qu'il aime bien et sur
cahier il prend et puis on prend ce qui
prend des cinq maintenant ça va pas
marcher à cause d'un de ces cinq attaque
le pion F2 et la cavalière des 5 vous
voyez c'est tout naturel
il y a du Fou point F3 D4 qui traîne
aussi nous dit ouais sur faut deux
peut-être vous prend F3 et D4 ouais mais
bon même pas besoin même pas besoin de
se casser la tête même si on fait
tourger vite mais c'est vrai qu'il faut
prendre F3 et regarder avec des cartes
qui peut gagner du matériel ou pas et
non c'est très mauvais c'est très
mauvais Maxime
c'est très très mauvais à cause de fou
prendre des quatre et après qu'elle
prend 4 mais alors et pas en forme
aujourd'hui
qui traîne ah oui mais je déforme tes
propos
non mais tour G8 tranquillement et puis
il faut deux franchement on joue pas ce
genre de cours
enfin peut-être que si on a pas le choix
on va jouer mais c'est vrai que c'est
des agréable c'est ce clouage est très
désagréable 3
j'aime pas du tout parce que poser comme
ça doit aider des attaques des cibles
ça paraît ça paraît compliqué
BTP là qui reprend
c'est midi les gars
c'est incroyable ça
après on met une pièce en prise puis on
sait jamais à chaque coup faut regarder
si l'autre peut prendre ou pas et fouger
5 joules par ergy ok ok ok là là on a
une décision là
donc
on va calculer en bougeant les pièces en
plus simple si Dame prend
cavalier prend
on est obligé
une pièce
cavalier
qu'on va pas sortir donc à ma vie le
coup ici c'est vous prend le 4
et c'est jouer eux d'un projet 5
vous prendrez un jouet
et maintenant à mon avis ça va être le
coup ça va être fou prends le 4 c'est
jouer il faut prendre le 4 maintenant on
a le temps enfin Maxime je pense qu'il
va jouer rapidement
il change quoi le H3 avant il change que
ça fait une petite case de roi c'est
mieux comme ça en vrai
je sais pas si c'est
décisif mais
on préfère la voir parce que on s'est
fait une petite case voilà alors on
reprend de quel pion dessus là dessus là
on est obligé de reprendre parce que si
on recule avec le fou il faut prendre F5
échec donc la question
c'est de quoi reprendre ton
est-ce qu'on va prendre ce pion ou de ce
pion intuitivement moi j'aimerais bien
reprendre de spion pourquoi parce que ça
donne très joli centre au noir donc ça
peut être très sympa sur ça on fait ça
et attention menace
et éventuellement ça est-ce que je peux
pas jouer un petit coup un petit coup
sûr là attendez 7 on protège tout on
empêche cavalier F7 on va faire tourger
huile gentiment on a le fou qui va
rayonner en G7 ou en B4 ça c'est une
très très belle position pour les pour
les Noirs je crois que c'est ça le coup
il a joué quoi il a joué 34 il nous fait
pas mentir regardez-moi ça et sur
peut-être qu'il va faire qui prend du
coup mais en tout cas j'ai l'impression
sur tout reprendre le coup ça va être
tour des 7
tu aurais pris de ces intuitivement de F
ouais ouais non mais ouais on reprend
vers le centre toujours
on est bien là il est très très bien mvl
et en plus pas de risque
peut-être qu'elle va les prendre alors
qu'elle va les prendre menace toujours
mais on peut faire tourner 7
il y a quand même très bien on va pas se
qu'on a gagné qu'est-ce qu'on va aller
faire avec ce qu'il y avait attention
parfois il peut être enfermé aussi
donc ça peut être chaud
alors oui on peut difficilement perdre
c'est ça
et en plus on a plus de temps on a une
finale supérieure du blanc sont très
bien et les Noirs pardon
oh là là ça peut être énorme surtout
s'il Radjabov est pas bien en ce moment
pour avoir
si Yann il pourra voir quasiment c'est
pas surréaliste qu'il est un point
d'avance
au moins un point d'avance ça demande de
la fin ça serait quand même beau et ça
permettrait de voir
d'envisager l'avenir avec sérénité et
notamment la prochaine partie de quoi il
veut qu'est-ce qu'il veut faire je
comprends pas en fait bon il est en
train vraiment en train d'analyser ça et
là je crois il a joué
il va se prendre assez rapidement à mon
avis
je sais pas pourquoi mais je sens comme
ça et ton essai de jouer dans la seconde
et on est quand même très très bien
attention foubecane fougez cette menace
full B4 menace
et je vois pas trop ce qu'on fait avec
les Blancs il faut essayer de sauver sa
peau là c'est clair
puis ici c'est quand même un joueur très
agressif normalement il essaye
il aime bien avoir des
des positions actives
ouais pourquoi il y a pas Magnus Wiko
dans ce tournoi après faut voir que il y
a énormément de tournois c'est juste
après la Coupe du Monde il y a ce
champion de chest tour
donc ça paraît
il y a quand même beaucoup beaucoup de
tournois ils peuvent pas être partout
personne ne peut être partout
en 2019 tout à fait il a gagné le
tournoi en 2019 manuscrit pendant le
tournoi c'est un petit peu malade vous
pouvez voir cette cette partie conte
vite où il a les blancs et propose nul
au bout de 5 coups avec les Blancs ça
n'arrive jamais évidemment pour une
scarsen mais
il sentait pas bien
voilà bon c'est chose qui arrive quand
on veut en Inde
pour les Européens en tout cas et
inversement d'ailleurs quand les Indiens
viennent en France il peut y avoir des
petits des petits soucis
alors cavaliers 6 oui foudé 6 pour le
petit piège on peut toujours faire ça
mais bon évidemment il y a pas tombé
dans le piège donc on a envie de faire
du du long terme est en temps je trouve
parce que la structure quand même peut
être endommagée on n'a pas envie de
donner le fou a priori
on peut jouer un petit coup sur un c'est
6 bon ben on est toujours mieux mais on
n'a pas forcément envie de donner ce fou
on a envie de le garder plutôt
même si on a une très belle structure et
il joue fou B4 et A3 et oui il veut
empêcher le forcer la décision il prend
et il donne le fou mais en échange d'une
structure largement affaiblie est-ce que
cavalier A4 est pas un coup ici
cavalier C4
peut-être un petit coup de tout envie
d'abord il y a énormément de coups très
tentant les noirs sont beaucoup beaucoup
mieux
clairement
monstrueux ouais
il va falloir un moment ou un autre
protéger comme cette belle structure
peut-être c'est 6 j'aime bien faire ce
genre de cool d'abord c'est si c'est
ensuite on voit
ensuite on met le cavalier là comme ça
pas d'histoire
ok
mais oui sur quel c'est 5 on est obligé
d'aller sur cette cette colonne alors
que pas forcément vous voyez sur ces 6k
et ses 5 par exemple j'ai plutôt envie
de faire ton F7 et de m'organiser sur la
colonel en combinaison et le cavalier
qui va venir là ouh là ou la colonne
j'ai d'ailleurs
ouais vous voyez l'avantage de jouer ce
genre de coup avant de passer aux choses
sérieuses donc Maxime qui réfléchit qui
a une très belle position
il a vraiment il est en domination
clairement il a il a très très bien
réussi son ouverture excellent choix
d'ouverture
ouais et là sa technique qui a été
impériale hier on va voir s'il va
répéter
si va répéter cette
domination dans la technique
pas du tout pas du tout donc il y a pas
de place au candidat c'est juste c'est
juste c'est un tournoi qui joue beaucoup
pour la confiance la dernière chance de
Maxime pour les candidats ça sera le
tournoi grand Suisse qui ça évidemment
retransmission cheesecom FR
avec
Ali résafiruja Maxime va chez Lagrave
Jules Moussa Étienne maquereau et
Marc-André à maudit qui joueront pour
ces deux dernières places au candidats
sachant qu'à les raisins a aussi une
chance aux Hello
alors
il joue que directement
mvl OK
et oui j'oublie
c'est ça un cas toujours
quatre bonnes minutes d'avance pour mvl
il est là
il est là Maxime on fait à 4 on protège
le puron un petit coup de C6 Maxime un
peu vas-y
écoute c'est 6 comme ça pas d'histoire
pas d'histoire et on voit ensuite où on
met ses tours
on protège le pion la structure est
belle tout est parfait
pourquoi je joue pas Thomas latin
mais j'aimerais bien je peux inviter à
cet endroit là
ok ok il me fait mentir
j'aime pas j'aurais plutôt vu les tours
par là sur les
dommage
il vient aussi et voilà qui c'est ça que
je vous en parler maintenant on est
obligé de venir avec la tour sur une
case où on n'avait pas forcément envie
d'y aller
envie d'aller pardon
pour des 6
on peut pas tout à l'heure on donne un
pion si on fait ça apparemment ça a pas
l'air très bon de le prendre peut-être à
cause de ces cinq suivis de ça donc il y
aura le pion là
7 aussi le cavalier a l'air quand même
assez enfermé mais quand même
tour des 8 jouez par mvl
et c'est vrai qu'il aime c'est tout
ressemble derrière ses pions il y a rien
de catastrophique mais on aurait pu
envisager quelque chose d'encore plus
ambitieux alors attention à pas rater
son avantage ça serait dommage parce
qu'il a obtenu tellement facilement
et ça serait tellement beau de gagner à
ce moment-là du tournoi ouais enfin bon
évidemment toutes les rondes sont bonnes
à gagner mais là on arrive vraiment dans
les dernières rondes et ça mettrait un
coup au moral aux autres
alors ouais fin
jouer par ergy
ok on ramène le roi au centre c'est
logique peut-être 3 2 va arriver
comment on fait maintenant est-ce qu'on
chasse
on peut pas trop prendre le pion c'est 5
c'est enfermé ça c'est soit ça soit ça
c'est pas bon du tout
non il sert il s'est Maxime peut-être il
a un petit doute sur sur l'ampleur des
dégâts pour les blancs mais il sait très
bien que il sait très bien que les noirs
sont beaucoup beaucoup mieux
ça c'est une évidence
grâce à l'espace évidemment le centre la
meilleure structure
tout ça
tous ces éléments qui font que les noirs
sont beaucoup mieux il y a aussi ce
monstre en C4 vous voyez la différence
dans la structure de pion fait que le
cavalier en C4 est un des logeable c'est
ce que le cavalier en C5 sera tôt ou
tard chassé par ce pion en B6 donc il y
a pas de case stable pour le cavalier
aussi
E3 le problème c'est que tu menaces pas
grand chose j'ai l'impression quoi que
peut-être tu aurais faite qui arrive
ensuite pour attaquer F2 mais j'aime pas
trop 3
ces 4 est un avant poste une casser
forte nous demande robinside oh là là
on va t'envoyer un stage chez coach
aussi
c'est une casse forte
c'est une casserole
une case où on est un délogeable je vais
montrer un avant-poste
un avant-poste serait ici
ici si on mettait un cavalier ici ça
sera un avant-poste
non il faut le mettre en fait dans la
marche pas alors j'arrive
avant poste on peut être délogé par un
pion mais ça affaiblit le pion qui est
derrière
le pion qui est sur la même colonne bon
je vais pas être très clair
il y avait des désaccords sur la
définition à l'Alpe d'Huez dans ton gîte
ouais non mais par exemple dans une
structure
[Musique]
c'est juste devant le pur en fait bon là
c'est pas possible il faut qu'il y ait
un pion
admettons il y a plus pions
et bien du coup qu'est-ce qui devient
non c'est pas bon ça non plus faut qu'il
y ait plus de pions je montrerai
je montrerai pour la lavant-poste
je vous ferai un
voilà par exemple alors je vais montrer
ce que c'est en pause vas-y que comme
coach aussi dans la méthode
voilà
les quatre
E6 ça sonne avant poste pourquoi parce
que si on veut déloger le cavalier en
juin F6 mais on va affaiblir à ce
moment-là le pion aussi
voilà donc ça c'est un avant-poste
cette case de 5 étonnante clairement bon
revenons à nos moutons V6 on attaque le
cavalier qui est B3 je vois tempo et
maintenant on peut jouer vraiment contre
le cavalier on peut jouer c'est 5 on
peut jouer à 5 pour fixer ce pion on
peut jouer tout un tas de coups qui sont
très avantageux
voilà la différence
une case forte et donc on est en poste
un délogeable tout à fait
tout à fait c'est ça on peut ouais on
peut définir les choses comme ça
est possible mais de toi
et après comment on fait
alors ce qui est bien ici c'est que
c'est dur de perdre davantage parce que
c'est du long terme l'avantage avec ses
pions donc même une petite erreur c'est
pas si grave ça perd peut-être une
partie d'avantage mais pas tout
l'avantage
et la colonne doit être mis au verte
tout à fait Billy Jack la colonne doit
être semi ouverte
tout à fait pour nous
on n'a pas d'avant aussi notre colonne
en fait s'il y a un pion
il y a un pion
tout à fait
mais bon peu importe
c'est bien d'avoir EDF 6 minutes
attention 6 minutes quand on se fait 20
c'est la première fois du tournoi au
maximum et moins bien en temps il prend
son temps mais bon en même temps c'est
une finale assez simple donc il veut
vraiment réfléchir pour finaliser son
avantage
j'ai pas aimé ce qu'il a fait les
derniers coups vous voyez moi je pense
qu'il fallait plus s'organiser sur du C6
comme je vous l'avais dit et les tours
par là vous voyez Maxime qui hésitent
maintenant
il a joué quoi Maxime
archi concret j'aime pas ça mais bon son
style aussi
il menace tour fuite certainement
ok mais bon
même toi donc il y a pas vraiment de
menace de gagner la partie c'est vrai
que 3 c'est cohérent avec tout 8 tout à
fait
alors comment il va faire un Gazi il
peut pas prendre évidemment si on prend
que les prend fourchette
et terminer
donc E3 on va simplement
ignorer
est-ce qu'on peut faire ça
et je me hâte de prendre du coup mais
bon ça il y a certainement ça
et là on est pas bien et c'est vrai
qu'en fait avec ce coup de 3 on a quand
même dominer ce cavalier si je fais ces
cinq le cavaliers il a plus la case là
il a plus à case là là non plus là bon
c'est pas folichon et peut-être que
c'est un qui est le 2 mais attention
c'est pas c'est pas terrible non plus
et empêcher tour est fuite joli
joli coup de la part d'art June
intéressant
intéressant ok donc maintenant comment
on fait avec ce pion si on le pousse on
va le perdre
je crois qu'on va le perdre
on va attaquer ça quoi que la jauge à
part convaincu peut-être F3 au F2
pourquoi un jour j'ai pas convaincu ça
ça m'étonne un peu
a pas l'air d'être le coup quoi que
ouais certainement
tour des 4
et il n'aime pas du tout peut-être c'est
ça et puis
cette C4 qui prend 4 par exemple comme
ça
ça va pas du tout pour les blancs
donc cette fois l'air A1 et ensuite on
va jouer F3 en F2 on s'est un peu
affaibli quand même pas trop mais en
même temps quoi faire alors la menace en
menace de prendre mais c'est pas non
plus une menace mortelle parce qu'on
peut reprendre du cavalier on va
attaquer un peu tous les pions donc
c'est pas mal
attention Maxime quand même 5 minutes
contre 6
faux alors effectivement ça laisse quand
même beaucoup de temps on rappelle il y
a 10 secondes par coup donc tout va bien
mais bon
on a moins de temps pour pour réfléchir
il a joué ses cinq Maxime va chez
agrafes il contrôle cette case des
quatre
effectivement c'est pas un moment de
bonheur pour les blancs mais quand même
c'est mieux qu'il y a 10 coups voilà la
situation s'est améliorée ça c'est très
clair
pas au point d'être excellente mais au
point d'être quasi objectifs
c'est une bonne question
j'aime bien ça
qu'est-ce qu'on veut sur un 5 parce que
si je prends ici on reprend
on reprend
tout simplement
pour reprendre maintenant qu'il prend à
5 bon ben la finale de tour oui
certifiable de tour mais elle va être
compliqué quand même
par exemple avec le pion à passer
la tour va reculer on va pousser on va
la tour derrière
ça avance bien quand même on peut aussi
faire Rober 5 roise C4 éventuellement ça
a quand même pas mal pour les Noirs tout
ça
alors c'est 5 il a joué puis on prend le
3 et tout reprend le 3 je vais par
Maxime qui menace tu reprends ces trois
du coup qui force plus ou moins tu
reprends le 3 j'ai l'impression
on va voir
oh là là le BTP là
perceuse
je vais fermer la fenêtre c'est l'enfer
il arrête il arrête quand je me menace
de me lever pour faire un fenêtre
il nous écoute en fait non
on construit le stade la piscine
olympique
ils sont pas en avance hein je vous le
dis
ouais
il le fait vraiment la fenêtre à son
truc là je sais pas ce qu'il fait je
sais pas ce qu'il fabrique
coupe des planches à foison
attaque la tour en attaque le pion bon
ben 5 minutes contre 4 je crois que
c'est l'heure d'aller dans le public
on va aller dans le public et on va
suivre tout ça on va se rapprocher on
est où là on va être bien on va être là
on est en méga VIP
on est très très bien
on voit le on est bien on est bien on
est bien on est parfait qu'est-ce qui a
été joué qui prend le 3 tours C1 a été
joué par mvl
par Erik et il a pas voulu jouer autour
des deux ça c'est une petite surprise
certainement qu'il avait peur de tout
refuer dessus de Tour Eiffel
mais qu'est-ce que c'est passif et A5
évidemment empêchant à 5 et empêchant
tout contre je kyidd2 rapidement il veut
activer son cavalier peut-être essayer
d'échanger ça peut être pas mal
à mes voisins
je
caresse mon voisin
je donne la main à mon voisin quasiment
alors
qui dit franchement que c'est pas trop
facile et tu écris mal ça se voit tu
vois tu mens pas il y a pas de y faire
ami je te remercie
alors D4 des 4 jouets et sur pion prend
on va faire tout reprendre c'est ça
l'idée OK
sur ces cas je suppose qu'il veut faire
des trois ouh là c'est 4 elle aime pas
elle aime pas la jauge pourquoi à cause
des trois non
regardez-moi ça c'est ça
il a pris oh là là
comme pour moi
ou il a pas vu hyper un pion en plus
d'être mal hyper un pion sur G4 et H5 et
on nous annonce la nul de rajabov donc
ça veut dire que ça veut dire ça veut
dire que Maxime va certainement avoir un
point d'avance après cette partie
incroyable
oh là là là là mauvais sens pour les
timer exact il a 5,25 entre 257 bien vu
bien vu cher ami et oui ça change toutes
les rondes c'est l'enfer
et j'ai 45
et on a un pion de plus tout est sur MML
mais il y a beaucoup de faiblesses et en
plus la tour est passif ça devrait être
gagnant facilement pour prendre les
quatre joues et par Maxime va chez
Lagrave
et Maxime ouh là là qui a profité là
d'une gaffe hein clairement
clairement une gaffe qui a donné un pion
hardjoon c'est pas trop son tournoi et
il le démontrait roi E2 il sait qu'il
est gagnant Maxime va chez Lagrave
comment va-t-il terminer le travail
comment on fait
comment on fait ce qu'on peut faire un
truc comme ça roi des trois qui est G4
peut-être mais ça c'est intéressant mais
il va nous trouver un truc qui va nous
trouver un truc peut-être tourgé trois
aussi pour me masser qui est français
dessus D3 ça peut être intéressant cette
tour et affreusement passive
de tourgé de jeu roi des trois le seul
coup et maintenant peut-être que j'ai 4
pour faire cavalier 5 ou peut-être
tourger 3 pour menacer un échec à
découvertes
beaucoup d'options très tentantes faut
faire attention on peut aussi ramener le
roi quoi que si on ramène le roi on va
certainement
on peut certainement activer la tour
avec les Blancs donc on va pas faire ça
alors
on va voir mais là c'est une très bonne
nouvelle là pour Maxime qui joue G4
menace qui gagne la partie quasiment sur
le champ ou cavalier F2 échec aussi
menace par exemple si tours tour ici et
bien échec 3 E2 échec roi bouge tour
reprend tout reprend et allez vas-y je
ramasse toute la petite famille à une
dame donc là faut faire attention faut
jouer un coup de cavalier je suppose
je suppose qu'il faut jouer un coup de
cavalier mais alors
mais alors que c'est dur que c'est dur
ouais il va pas le louper normalement il
reste de 37 pour irigaty qui vient de
gâcher qui nous a largement simplifié la
tâche en garants
et ouais il a joué un peu vite sur un
coup mais bon il était sous pression
depuis le début de la partie il a
carrément raté son ouverture c'était un
désastre tout simplement ouverture
désastreuse de la part des reggae
alors comment il va faire maintenant
quand il va faire peut-être cavalier 4
car il y a 4 cavaliers
attention attention le public applaudit
s'il y a cavalier
F2 roi E2 cavalier E4 qu'est-ce qu'il
veut faire sur roi des trois qui va être
joué on va le on va le savoir bientôt
peut-être qu'elle est C3 qui est ces
trois attaque le pion et si tu auras un
hop là
et si je jouais
et c'est terminé
rideau et oui oh là là il va se lever 5
29 contre 2 est-ce qu'il se lève il
s'emmerde
et il s'emmerde et je lève les bras je
lance là où là mais personne ne me suit
les Indiens sont mauvais perdants
et oui Maxime qui se balade
tourrache un tour G3
on adore on adore
il fait chèque là vraiment échec donc il
va faire par là
non il fait roi roi qui vient sur la
tour et tour et fuite OK
pas obligé d'encaisser le pion on peut
encaisser le pion
mais c'est pas obligatoire quoique
comme ça essayer de s'infiltrer mais bon
on va voir comment on fait pour laisser
aucun contrôle j'ouvre 7 mvl tour F4 et
tour H3 et lui dit à toi de jouer
effectivement si il fait roi des deux
maintenant il peut prendre le pion et le
Roi peut pas s'avancer
c'est tellement déprimant pour un
il va pas abandonner il va jeton F5
c'est quasiment certain
et il a joué non
vas-y ok ça
il prend pas tour à chemin
ça joue méchant si roi des trois tours
donc ça ne va pas donc il faut jouer
cavalier 1 seul coup pour pas vendre
tout de suite c'est jouer et maintenant
et maintenant qu'on a pacifié tout le
monde qu'est-ce qu'on fait et l'encaisse
enfin ok bien joué et sur cavalier qui
revient en revient et c'est terminé il a
laissé aucun contre je voyais vous voyez
c'est très important non non ils sont
pas de sa gueule
il joue il joue il le fait pas tourner
en beau et qui joue pour que heregazing
et aucun contre jeu ça n'a rien à voir
avec de la moquerie c'est pas du tout ça
c'est surtout pour pas se faire arnaquer
le plus sûr moyen de pas se faire
arnaquer c'est de donner aucun contre
jeu à votre adversaire quand vous êtes
complètement gagnant et c'est ce que
fait à merveille mvl dans cette
situation roi des 6 qui est ces trois va
arriver
il va abandonner
ça sent l'abandon
abandon
il a joué c'est pas possible
donc j'ai 4 OK
mais n'importe quel coup gagne le
cavalier qui est ces trois par exemple
qui est B2 est fort aussi
non mais c'est très bien on peut on peut
jamais bouger le Calais il y a Matt et
on va envoyer le pion a
tout simplement
un petit échec de consolation mais ça ne
sert absolument à rien on peut aller se
planquer en 6 ou on veut
vous pouvez même donner espion mais il y
a pas besoin aucun contre jeu boom VL
il fait chèque mais là il joue il joue
longtemps c'est étonnant
parce que franchement là c'est quand
même c'est très abandonnable
c'est on peut on peut abandonner la
conscience tranquille et on peut
applaudir dans le public c'est un peu ça
commence à applaudir en public voilà les
Indiens d'ombre là
ça applaudit dans le public
ou pas
non non non mais là
quand même
et allez à le plan il est pas dur là
non c'est terminé c'est étonnant il
continue à jouer
alors il fait tout recettes il protège
mais Maxime qui se pose pas la question
il fait à 4 évidemment
et à trois prochains coups et même les
petites combinettes ne marche pas
tout marche pour les Noirs vraiment
c'est fantastique
c'est fantastique tout ça marche donc la
4 c'est la position est-ce qu'il
abandonne ou pas voilà je je
parle même plus d'abandon parce que
tellement ça fait 10 coups genre
abandonné franchement c'est étonnant
hein cette nouvelle génération ils
abandonnent pas facilement
3 8 à 3 mais ça sert à rien là parce
qu'il a aucune chance de s'en sortir à
trois évidemment jouer
il a vu bravo à lui et c'est bon ça
il n'y a pas de pâte il y a 54 pour le
roi
oh là il le regarde il lui a lancé un
regard mdr en mode bon
tu es sympa mon pote
mais quand même tu as le droit
d'abandonner avec ta minute
incroyable non on a le droit non mais on
va pas se plaindre on a le droit à un
moment donné quand on veut moi j'ai
l'impression moi quand je fais ça je me
faisais du mal quand même parce qu'on le
sait quoi je veux dire c'est 100%
100% sur que il la perd
il n'y a aucune chance aucune chance
zéro
c'est du zéro c'est du 100 % d'ailleurs
on met 5 et demi sur 7 on met le score
donc je vais me faire je vais me faire
huer pour ça je vais faire U et pour ça
mais je mets le score
je mets le score voilà je mets le score
c'est 100% annoncé je mets le score et
Maxime il aimerait pas ça si vous voyez
mais il voit pas 5 et demi sur 7 voilà
alors
5 tours géant
parce que la tour a plus de casse sur la
colonneuse tu fais roi des deux à deux
et dames ça va abandonner
ou pas vous avez déjà surpris plus une
fois
mvl 5e et demi sur 7
non mais bon là
à deux
ouais il abandonne je vous avais dit
et donc
roi des deux il a joué à deux il a
réfléchi un peu il a abandonné bon
facile facile pour un VL on va aller
voir s'il y a d'autres parties en cours
est-ce qu'il y a une autre partie en
cours
sur une autre caméra
c'est terminé j'ai l'impression tout est
terminé
et non ça joue chez gamer gritchouk Arna
gamer gretchouk ou
Abdou satorov
oh moi j'ai envie de voir Sacha j'aime
bien voir Sacha allez on va voir Sacha
je me
suis toujours toujours très fan
de glitchouk
face
aux jeunes gamer et on met les pendules
bien comme il faut on a les chéquier qui
est mieux pourquoi on sait pas
de joueurs qui ont des fortunes diverses
mais on se rappelle il a donné il a
donné la dame hier
un seul coup qui meurt une journée rude
mais il est bien là il a une qualité en
plus et le roi quand même qui est qui
est passé du tout
d'accord c'est très gentil merci
merci au revoir
pourquoi Sacha
c'est diminutif d'Alexander en russe
et du coup ouais bon
quand on connaît les gens on peut les
appeler comme ça sachant en fait c'est
comme ça qu'on l'appelle en russe c'est
son prénom en fait il a été juste
anglicisé mais en russe c'est Sacha grec
j'appelle par son prénom je connais bien
du coup et puis il se fait appeler comme
ça par tout le monde donc
voilà des trois il a quand même dû
contre jeu et Tours C8 qui est une gaffe
apparemment pourquoi pourquoi c'est une
gageure c'est rien on mena c'est chèque
et matte en général c'est pas mal sur un
truc peut-être tour des 6 pour essayer
de pousser on va voir ce que va jouer
Sacha
et ouais il est envoyé une pétrole MV la
gagner 5 et demi sur 7 il est premier
avec un point d'avance
un point d'avance rendez-vous compte
tour des 6 jouets en menace des deux et
il fait il nous fait une Master Class là
depuis un jour
et c'est pas mal c'était le bon couteau
des ciseaux logiques en plus
faut qu'elle trouve va-t-il où va-t-il
pose-moi ça
quelque chose si il voit rien de spécial
il va pousser il a poussé
c'est poussé
et il fait pousser deux ok ça ça
on peut pas faire de la main parce qu'il
y a la cavalier qui traîne à la fin ok
j'ai 4 et une option aussi que j'ai 4 kg
3 attention deux options ok G6 aussi une
option ok il menace dame du coup fouder
peut-être tout aussi
ça a l'air pas mal quand même
il faut essayer de déloger ce fou qui
est gênant autour aussi se jouer par
Alexander Sacha comme vous voulez
tout aussi se menace tout
et ouais ça fait plaisir c'est vrai que
ça fait plaisir de voir maximum en forme
alors effectivement c'est pas dans le
cycle des candidats mais peu importe
c'est la confiance
et il va falloir emmager de la confiance
pour pour effectivement ce
ce tournoi qui arrive qui est une étape
importante évidemment ce tournoi à l'île
de Man alors effectivement ça lui fera
pas rentrer avec plus de points dans le
temps à l'île de Mans ce résultat dans
ce tournoi mais quand même
mais quand même c'est c'est quoi qu'il
arrive c'est très important
si jamais bon de faire un mauvais
tournoi ton G5 et ouais F6 menace et des
5 qui avait le 3 et il s'est fait avoir
gamer il s'est fait complètement avoir
il se fait retourner dans toutes les
parties
on la tour G8 mais là on gagne une pièce
qui prend estoreux oh là là quelque
chose il a mis en prise sa tour il a pas
vu il a pas vu du tout
oh là là c'est incroyable
il prend et je tourne il a une pièce de
plus il va gagner je vais voir si
l'autre partie incroyable cette gaffe et
il met des pieds sont prises gamer il
est pas bien gamer alors après le voyage
est long décalage horaire
si on regarde on peut être malade on
peut arriver
et en train de battre avec krishnaie un
peu plus
à torov qui est en train de battre à la
Krishna
c'est quoi c'est une filleule de pion
attention et finale de pion ouais mais
là ça gagne puis on passait éloigner au
F3 et vas-y je te pousse je te pousse
frangin ah non F5 ça sera sur échec non
mais en F3 est plus sûr F3 roi des 5 3
et au 4 G4 5 j'ai 5 5 j'ai 6 ça gagne
sur ça et non ça va pas gagner ça ça
gagne au tempo on va prendre ce pion
il joue rav3 on va voir la technique on
va voir je pense qu'il va ils vont jouer
cette variante 3D 5
qui va jouer il doit jouer 3 à mon avis
où j'ai quatre doigts gagner aussi
il joue quoi et je crois Abdou E4 gk35
G5 ouais 5g63 prend en reprend c'est la
partie regardez regardez où là il a
l'air sûr de lui
il va faire au F6 3D 5 on empêche
évidemment on empêche le roi de revenir
il la connaît sa finale
il a joué que une confiance extrême
parce que roi F6 roi D5 roeuse 7 rois et
6 et là très important que A4 puis on
prend roi des 8 on se dirige vers la
colonne la case à 8 meilleures
et c'est comme ça que ça gagne
et sur
F6 roi des 5 7 3 6 3D 8 on va B5 moi
c'est 7 3 B7 et roi B5 très important
l'opposition et si on va d'un côté on va
de l'autre avec son roi
et ça gagne Abdou sa torov qui est
content d'avoir gagné
ouais ça fait plaisir pour Maxime alors
attention c'est pas fini il reste de
ronde ça sera les plus chaudes
dans le public on va se hop là
et
on va voir effet Roy F6 à Krishna il va
jouer bon là il y a pas de mal à la
jouer un petit peu roi des seins
rois et 6 jouets comme je vous le
montrais roi des 8 va être joué où il va
abandonner je sais pas
recette
6 abandon et oui il a compris évidemment
il n'y a pas voulu aller jusqu'au bout
il sait très bien que c'est perdant et
victoire de nord du bec à dos qu'est-ce
que ça nous donne au niveau des
résultats regardez les résultats
victoire de Maxime Vacher la grave
tu es mort ajabov quoi c'est pas fini
entre non Sacha elle a gagné cette
partie quand même sinon on va se fâcher
encore pardon pardon pardon pardon
autant pour moi
autant pour moi j'avais j'étais
complètement sûr que grichu qui avait
terminé et je rencontre des histoires
voilà
premier rang
et donc Richou qui a une pièce de plus
mais est-ce que ça demande encore un peu
de technique en fait non
non non ça ne demande aucune technique
c'est beau ça quand on peut être
incompétent et gagner quand même
il va faire tourner ces trois voilà pas
besoin d'être compétent pour faire ton
C3 et après ça gagne tout seul et même
regarder la case c'est la bonne case
donc au pire même si on échange ses
pions ça va être gagnant
ouais Vincent ces jeunes joueurs qui ont
du mal à abandonner bon évidemment voilà
j'ai fait abandonner victoire de
gretchup sur gaffe de gamer il était
gagnant
Vincent dur pour lui très dur pour lui
ce tournoi
on va regarder les résultats victoires
de gretchup donc victoire surtout ce
qu'on retiendra de cette rampe c'est la
victoire de Maxime Vacher La Grave
combiné à la nulle de temorajabov contre
goût Kesh victoire de Prague contre
visite Abdou Sator abattu avec Krishna
comme on l'a vu
et
on va regarder
maintenant
les résultats
Maxime Vacher la grave il a fait le
classement pardon 5 points et demi sur 7
thémoradja BOV Catherine sur 7 donc un
point d'avance pour ml
c'est très beau un point et demi
d'avance sur Prague et a priori ils sont
quand même définitivement lâchés
aussi de l'ennemis avec les stars c'est
dur pour eux ils auront le Blitz
peut-être demain et après demain pour se
refaire on verra mais pour l'instant les
concentrés sur le rapide maintenant on
va regarder ces appareils en de la
prochaine ronde
que se passe-t-il sur la prochaine ronde
et bien on aura Maxime va chez La Grave
avec les Blancs contre penthala Harry
Krishna il a un point d'avance admettons
si il gagne
si il gagne que Raja bof nul et bien
c'est déjà c'est déjà terminé et Raja
BOV pour aller noir contre irigat ok bon
ça c'est un gros appareil humain aussi
une partie qu'on va suivre franchement
il doit mettre le point sur un Krishna
franchement
je sais pas moi je serai je serai petit
joueur dans ce cas là avec un point
d'avance j'attends de faire nul mais bon
effectivement il est dans une forme
olympique donc il va il va jouer c'est
sûr
regardez il a un point d'avance quand
même je veux dire objectivement la nul
c'est pas un désastre
si point il faudrait que rajabov gagne
les deux dernières sachant que Raja bof
joue contre MVA la dernière mais c'est
vrai qu'une victoire lui garantirait
garantirait
une première place execo ouais vraiment
scénario
donc c'est beau
ouais
mais bon c'est pour ça que je me
retrouve pas cinq et demi sur 7 aussi ça
fait déjà plusieurs parties que je
serais tenté de faire nul pour tout vous
avouer
honnêtement ouais j'aurais peut-être
Molly un petit peu avant donc on va
suivre tout ça la prochaine ronde est à
13h donc on va faire une petite pause je
vais ouvrir la fenêtre parce que j'ai
l'impression que le BTP fait une pause
une pause déj'
je vais mettre une petite musique mais
restez parce que franchement on a
mvl 5 et demi sur 7 un point d'avant sur
le deuxième un point et demi sur les
troisièmes franchement c'est quand même
incroyable on rappelle ce sont deux
tournois distincts donc si Maxime dans
deux parties est toujours premier il
gagne le droit de partir à rapide il
prend en remettre une couche pour le
Blitz ça serait beau de faire ce doubler
on espère
évidemment
tout ça le meilleur pour notre mvl
national c'est à suivre prochaine partie
je me reconnecte d'ici
7 minutes mes prochaines parties qui
recommence à 13 heures
heure parisienne sur ce merci de me
suivre et rester le plus intense et à
venir les blancs contre arraché dans la
prochaine à tout de suite
saviez-vous que vous pouvez pimenter vos
parties en ligne et vous analysez avec
des emojis il vous suffit de cliquer sur
l'icône emoji puis de sélectionner votre
emoji et de cliquer avec le bouton
gauche de la souris sur l'échiquier vous
pouvez choisir parmi une multitude de
notation de coûts d'animation
d'émoticônes et même vos personnalités
préférées du monde des échecs des
émoticônes et les emojis disparaîtront
au bout de quelques secondes en revanche
les notations de coûts les animations
spéciales restent sur l'échiquier
jusqu'à ce qu'elle soit effacées pour ce
faire il suffit de cliquer avec le
bouton gauche de la souris sur l'emoji
ou de cliquer sur le bouton Tout effacer
essayez tous et amusez-vous bien sur
Chess.com
[Musique]
et je suis de retour pour cette ronde 8
du tournoi rapide il y a 9 ronds donc il
reste plus que deux parties et la bonne
nouvelle c'est Maxime va chier la grave
qui est en tête du classement avec 5 et
demi sur 7 1 point d'avance sur adjabov
performance xxl de la part de mvl
qui a pris une première journée plus
difficile clairement mais ça aide très
bien sorti avec de sur 3 et que ce
tournant contre visite depuis nous fait
Master Class sur Master Class du 3 et
demi sur 4 sur les quatre dernières même
quatre et demi sur cinq avec la partie
compte vite mais trois demi sur 4 archi
convaincant
très très bon très très bon mvl on a
vous avez le classement qui a été
épinglé par Robinson que l'on remercie
que vous pouvez suivre aussi sur les
réseaux sociaux de cheesecom fr Twitter
enfin x
Twitter x Facebook et je suppose
Instagram je sais pas si je l'ai
instagram sur mais c'est sûr qu'il y a
un Instagram je sais pas s'il est très
actif chaise comme fr
donc voilà vous pouvez suivre toutes les
news et ne rater aucun
aucun live
si vous avez envie évidemment et puis si
vous n'avez pas envie vous regardez ce
qui vous plaît et vous avez tous les
news des échecs en général donc
n'hésitez pas à le faire ensuite
on a oui deuxième question c'est
simplement le tournoi rapide les scores
ne s'ajoutent pas c'est si Maxime est
toujours en tête après la ronde neuf il
aura gagné le tournoi rapide et en
partira demain et après demain sur un
tournoi de Blitz on va regarder les
appariements de cette huitième ronde et
la première qui nous intéresse c'est mvl
avec les Blancs contre avec Krishna et
ce qui nous intéresse dans une moindre
mesure parce que Maxime machin grave à
son destin entre les mains c'est rajabov
contre reggae
voilà ce qui nous intéresse aussi c'est
de savoir pourquoi
il met les coups de perceuse à midi je
reviens je reviens
c'est dommage que je puisse pas filmer
franchement parce que c'est étonnant ce
truc il coupe une planche et j'ai
l'impression qu'il coupe toujours la
même planche mais bon
ouais normalement Maxime va chez Lagrave
Maxime Vacher la grave il est
il est il est plus la cadence accélère
mais il est normalement il est champion
il a été champion du monde de 8 en 2021
donc ça ça a quand même ça en dit ça dit
quelque chose
et comme nous le dit docteur bilbas
apparemment il revient dans le top 3
rapide il a déjà été numéro un mondial
en rapide mais il est quand même il est
quand même assez incroyable
on le sait que c'est tout meilleur
joueur du monde en rapide
et encore plus j'ai envie de dire en
blitz si j'avais dû parier j'aurais
parié sur sa victoire autour de beats
mais certes peut-être pas certainement
pas autora de partir rapide c'est plus
une surprise en rapide évidemment on va
se mettre sur ça
les deux vues pour vous pour que vous
ayez les chéquier en live
et l'échec qui est
le Grand Échiquier où j'essaye de vous
expliquer ce qui se passe
et ça va recommencer d'ici deux petites
minutes on peut se faire un live sur
toutes les caméras
elles sont toutes des caméras
Maxime qui a installé
j'essaie de parler mais j'ai pas le
micro sur ce sur cette vue là on a
visité
on va trouver Maxime
Maxime FASA à Cristina de joueurs qui se
connaissent très très bien de joueurs
Annie roi d'ailleurs
annuaire le nouveau champion de France
par équipe
qui a battu ce les tortues Bischwiller
à noter qu'il y aura l'inauguration d'un
square et oui un square Maxime va chier
lagraphe peut-être qu'il faut faire une
avenue maintenant il y a square Maxime
va chez Lagrave qui est trop inauguré le
13 septembre à Asnières-sur-Seine et oui
incroyable
de son vivant on lui donne il donne des
noms de Square alors avenue une ville
un pays peut-être le pays va chez La
Grave le pays Maxime va chez Lagrave
pour être beau pour être baptiser tout
ça en tout cas il y aura il y aura il y
a une rue crânienne déjà ouais
exactement
mais en tout cas il y aura un square
square mvl très beau
et on va voir comment va aborder cette
partie comment il aborde
Maxime et joue au 4 comme d'hab E4 5 ou
à Saint joueur d'espagnol à Krishna
alors est-ce qu'on va voir une nouvelle
écossaise je pense pareil oui on revient
sur espagnol quelque chose de plus
classique alors évidemment il va pas
forcer la nul mais il va pas prendre de
risque démesuré
ou non ok j'ai eu peur de la répétition
mais je tourne voilà
tout en souplesse
il aura peut-être une petite idée il va
pousser sans prendre de risque dans
cette berlinoise avec tours c'est
vraiment
alors attendez
voilà comme ça vous avez la position en
live on va voir on va voir assez
rapidement si il veut plus que la nul ou
pas
a priori oui parce qu'il pouvait faire
cette répétition très connue
alors des quatre ok tout est normal en
général je vous faut F6 et tout re 8
cavalier 8 et un autre coup ici il y a
deux écoles
on va voir
a priori fou F6 c'est quand même le coup
F6 joué et tour 2 ouais un petit coup
qu'on a travaillé déjà à l'époque en
pour Magnus Carlsen il avait joué dans
son match contre Sergei kayakin ça peut
pas vraiment être une surprise pour
Harry Krishna
l'idée c'est de pouvoir reprendre de la
dame en E2 et de pouvoir doubler
rapidement par exemple surtout huit on
va faire
cavalier ces trois tours 2 et voyez la
différence avec
l'autre c'est clair on va faire faux F4
et on va faire tourner et on va pouvoir
doubler
mais surtout aux deux il décide de faire
cavalier C4 et oui c'est rendu possible
par ça on va faire en menace dessin
suivi de cavalier revient donc a priori
oui il faut chasser le cavalier tout de
suite
et
bon qui est ici n'aurait aucun sens
clairement disons-le
on reviendrait on aurait donné de temps
au blanc
mais l'option c'est plutôt qui est B6 ou
cavaliers 5 c'est vraiment un coup
cavalier à 5 je crois pas
alors c'est le petit plus sans risque
c'est la situation parfaite pour mvl
clairement
après si il fait nul et que Raja bof
gagne bien ça donne une dernière ronde
un petit peu nerveuse c'est ça le truc
il y a un point
vous pouvez le suivre d'un œil
pour voir ce qu'il fait
alors que des trois
ok pourquoi Dame des trois
c'est une bonne question à déposer des
questions auxquelles j'ai pas j'ai pas
la réponse vu que je suis seul c'est
quand même embêtant
je crois qu'il y a pas de départage en
cas d'égalité en tout cas c'est pas
c'est pas stipulé dans le règlement je
l'ai pas vu dans le règlement pourtant
je l'ai lu à plusieurs reprises
donc Dame des trois bon bah ça fait que
ah c'est pour faire qu'il y ait des deux
sans perdre le pion ok j'ai compris
il a envie de c'est vrai que le cavalier
en des deux est un F3 ou des deux quatre
est bien placé donc les dames des trois
d'abord ce pion est protégé et ensuite
il va pouvoir développer ses pièces
pour garder la case F5 aussi des 5 x 5
c'est vrai que ça peut être une façon de
se développer parce que regarder si on
faisait un développement normal et c'est
3D 5 ce cavalier on va pas trop où il va
est-ce que sur
m3 qui est D2 si on fait des 5 à ce
moment-là on va pouvoir aller à F3 avec
le cavalier Dame des trois il fait des 5
évidemment
est-ce que Maxime va jouer cavalier des
deux je pense que oui ou alors X3
d'abord je sais pas
si je vous casser trois là il me fait
mentir complètement
est-ce qu'on peut faire un 4 aussi pour
déstabiliser ce cavalier en V6 beaucoup
d'options ici pour les blancs Maxime
connait très bien c'est un joueur
vraiment de ouf
qui joue H3
il veut empêcher aussi fougère donc il
joue clairement contre le footcas
blanche et c'est vrai que oui j'avais
pas pensé mais qui est des deux fougères
était un peu désagréable parce que c'est
attaqué la tour cavalier F3 on n'a pas
envie de s'auto clouer
et si on bouge la tour le fou va revenir
ici sur une très belle diagonale donc il
joue vraiment
contre les pièces est-ce que
Maxime Diniz
va se lever pas encore
on l'a vu beaucoup se lever dans ce
tournoi mais ça lui réussit bien c'est
du 25 + 10 donc il y a un peu le temps
alors faut aussi c'est maintenant
comment on fait a priori Dame des 7 je
sais pas je trouve ça un peu mousse
qu'il a fait Maxime
je pense qu'il va pas avoir grand chose
honnêtement Dame des trois H3
vous voyez c'est pas un truc de qui
réfute après sur Dame des 7 x 5 il va
mettre la dame en G3
on sait pas si mal finalement je retire
ce que j'ai dit allez
et il y a un problème avec ce cavalier
il va falloir le remettre à un moment ou
un autre qui est C8 qui est D6 ou qui
est C8 qui est G6 quelque chose comme ça
ça m'étonnerait pas de voir qu'elle est
C8 ici honnêtement
le cavalier est très mal placé
peut-être c'est simple aussi pour jouer
dynamique sur le pion sur le pion des
fais comment ici
je vois pas trop de bon coup c'est 3
mais bon
tout mou
peut-être c'est trois vous me direz ok
des 7 à ce moment-là ou alors le plan
consacré normalement c'est de vraiment
replacer cavalier en dessin qui est la
case
normalement pour le cavalier
il faut gagner contre c'est pas
obligatoire attention il faut se méfier
de ces parties en premier et dernier
parfois ça tourne mal
donc méfions-nous
j'aime beaucoup le choix d'ouverture de
Maxime attention à Christina c'est pas
un débutant
énormément d'expérience gros joueur Dame
des 7 jouets
pour jouer évidemment
des joueurs indiens il y a quelques
joueurs indiens qui vit en Europe il vit
à
très connu en Europe clairement
après maintenant il y a tellement de
choses qui sont organisées en Inde que
ça va se faire de moins en moins je
suppose
ce déménagement des joueurs indiens même
un an dans l'espace de nombreuses années
donc il vit plus à Prague docteur bigbas
ou là je me fais réfuter par docteur
Bilba je crois pas
pas sûr peut-être qu'il vit à practer je
comprends parce que son épouse est serbe
si pas de bêtises
mais cela ne nous regarde pas
et donc je pensais qu'il habitait en
Serbie qu'est-ce qu'il a fait un tour
pas Prague c'est possible aussi enfin
pour les voyages voilà un an avec lui
aussi en Espagne
[Musique]
et donc c'est simplement parce que voilà
il joue beaucoup de tournois en Europe
et je voulais League et donc ça devient
plus simple
alors
il a vécu aussi en Allemagne il avait un
appartement en Allemagne Vichy en Inde
mais maintenant il est rentré il est
rentré à Chennai
je crois
intégralement il vient il vient beaucoup
moins en Europe évidemment il joue
beaucoup moins alors il me fait mentir
Maxime des deux cavaliers F3 il voulait
peut-être le faire mais apparemment ça
ça lui plaît moins
alors est-ce qu'on fait pour huit ou
est-ce qu'on fait 5 ou 11 est-ce qu'on
fait qui est C8 et qui est D6 c'est ça
la question comment on a fait Dame des 7
à mon avis on va plutôt faire fu F5 ça
serait ça serait logique mais il faut F5
ah non pas
donc on est obligé de reculer oui donc
ça sert d'être un bon deal quand même
en faire culé la Dame des deux
et si tu auras 8 voyez on fait tour à 1
et vous voyez l'intérêt d'avoir
la tour en E2 c'est qu'on peut c'est
beaucoup moins facile pour les noirs de
contester la colonne
qu'on pourrait faire C6 ici et tout va
bien franchement pour les noirs
qu'est-ce qu'il va faire il va jouer
par mvl qui joue très vite son petit
plus à cause du cavalier une fois que le
cavalier est là
il y a plus rien du tout donc attention
quand même
enfin bon
on va voir
partie pas on va regarder on va regarder
vite fait ce que
[Musique]
ce qui se passe sur
une fois vraiment
parce que c'est quand même notre
concurrent direct
on va regarder l'ouverture
et une kalachnikov ok donc une cage
nikov ça veut dire que Raja BOV il
essaye tente quelque chose là clairement
avec F5 assez agressif bon ça reste
solide quand même pour les pour les
blancs évidemment mais voilà Raja bof
qui joue la gagne à fond
les blancs sont pas mal donc tout va
bien pour égayer ça peut gagner aussi
mais ça sera une partie une partie assez
intéressante
qu'on
jettera un œil avec un intérêt
particulier évidemment intéressé
intéressé parce qu'au cas
au cas où les deux joueurs feraient nuls
ce qui me semble être le plus probable
dans la situation actuelle disons de
nuls des deux joueurs et bien
Maxime aborderait cette dernière onde
avec un point d'avance sur un jabov
dernière ronde à jouer ensemble mais
Maxime aurait déjà garanti la victoire
au moins execo du tournoi
première place execo après avoir
amélioré en fonction du résultat de la
dernière partie
alors j'ai trop chaud je suis vraiment
désolé je vais ouvrir la fenêtre parce
que j'ai trop chaud je crois que notre
ami a pris sa pause déjeuner on l'espère
notre ami est toujours là
incroyable incroyable
je travaille à 13h à midi à 13h il
travaille
en retard là les JO en du retard
je vous le dis
alors qu'est-ce qui s'est passé tour à
un tour à 8 vous voyez bon
ce que je vous avais dit
on sent
qu'est-ce qu'il veut faire
un petit coup de A4 ça sert plus à rien
parce que le justement il y allait le
cavalier
ça paraît très bah oui alors c'est
symétrique alors évidemment il reste des
pièces sur échiquier mais ça paraît
quand même très très égal
je sais pas quel est le départage pour
savoir qui est premier
mais
[Musique]
effectivement on verra on en est pas là
on en est pas là je pense que les
joueurs dans un tour à fermer en général
on considère que les joueurs sont
premiers execo on a joué les mêmes
joueurs on a fait le même nombre de
points bon bah il y a pas de raison de à
moins que on tient en compte le nombre
de parties jouées avec les noirs
et donc effectivement
à ce moment là il me semble que Maxime
gagnerait parce qu'il a joué plus de
parties avec les noirs
alors qu'est-ce qu'il a joué Maximy
toujours
pas évident j'ai quatre un peu trop peu
trop les
c'est trop
non
je voulais ma filtrer comme ça mais il
faut prendre ces deux
ça n'irait pas donc attention
l'ouverture c'est une berlinoise tourin
très sexy
je sais pas je sais pas je crois que ils
vont être déclaré les deux vainqueurs du
tournoi
s'il y a une égalité mais bon on en est
pas là
alors comment il va jouer
là franchement honnêtement je vois pas
comment on pose des problèmes avec les
Blancs
et Maxime a pas l'air convaincu non plus
il réfléchit parce qu'il sait très bien
si je vois un ou deux coups un peu
neutre maintenant mais les Noirs vont se
facilement s'organiser et égaliser la
position
donc clairement c'est maintenant ou
jamais
salut stuff notre ami touffe
quand c'est vas-y annonce nous tout
quand est-ce qu'est le prochain match de
speechess
vous pouvez suivre le speech
Championship qui a lieu en ce moment
qu'est-ce que c'est le speechers
Championship c'est c'est
le tournoi organisé par cheesecom pour
définir qui est le meilleur blitzer au
monde
on fait une heure trente de 5 + 1 c'est
un très beau format
une heure de trois plus en et 30 minutes
de 1 + 1
et on a qu'à moi gagné l'année dernière
Magnus évidemment est très bon dans ce
format les raisins aussi MV elle aussi
wesleaux aussi Niall Sarine est bon
aussi
bref ça donne ça donne des choses quand
même assez extraordinaire l'année
dernière on avait une finale pour
changer entre Carlsen et Nakamura
on a qu'à moral avait emporté c'était la
première fois alors que je crois qu'il y
avait eu avant il y a eu trois années où
Magnus l'avait emporté
mais clairement normalement il domine
mais bon avec des joueurs comme Ali resa
ou Maxime ça peut ça peut chatouiller ça
peut chatouiller du Magnus et d'une aka
maxime a déjà battu
a déjà battu
Maxime pardon a déjà battu Magnus dans
ce format donc tout est possible on sait
qu'il est très bon
alors pour aller en E3 et pour aller en
G4 certainement ok ok
il va jouer est-ce que va viser une
nulle pleutre ou jouer pour le gain il
va viser un gain de l'autre
mais gentiment voilà il cherche le gain
mais gentiment c'est nul c'est pas grave
voilà
essaie de poser quelques questions
oui oui je suis d'accord le format peut
vite devenir chiant et non mais
effectivement mais bon après quand c'est
serré c'est magnifique c'est ça
non il y avait des califes il y avait
des il y avait des califes pour ce
speech je crois qu'il y avait toujours
invité et 4 joueurs qualifiés quelque
chose comme ça ou 13 joueurs invités et
trois joueurs qualifiés
donc pour se qualifier bonne chance
c'est pas facile
ah ouais le grimpe l'autre c'est le
mieux
donc on est content
c'est ça c'est ce qu'il faut faire si
vous pouvez faire ça faites ça n'hésitez
pas
ouais non ça change tout est-ce que je
sais que la caméra est très fort en
Bullet mais est-ce que c'est un plus un
et significativement différent par
rapport au temps à Bullet qui avait lieu
oui ça change tout là en plus
ça fait c'est quasiment du 2 en fait
si on regarde la crème en fait qu'on
peut pas flaguer ça change énormément de
choses alors la caméra est toujours très
bon on s'inquiète pas pour Nakamura
mais moins beaucoup moins dominateur que
quand Bullet ça n'a rien à voir tu
reprends les deux jouer par
harrishna qui va
échanger je suppose
alors peut-être dame prend parce que sur
ton reprend on va faire tout 8 vas-y je
termine une couche par là cavalier 3
alors pour être un petit peu embêtant
attention Fuger 6 s'il y a peut-être qui
est G4 maintenant chatouille
c'est un peu désagréable ça et surtout
des 8 on va faire cavaler au 5 bon c'est
pas la fin du monde mais c'est pas très
agréable et tout reprend il a vu fou
prend Ok Go surprenant
donc clairement son idée c'est de faire
cavaler au 3 suivi cavalier G4
ouais il a pas envie de la jouer mais il
a pas envie de la perdre non plus il a
bien envie de faire annuler il est
content quand on a Maxime comme ça qui a
5 émissions 7 on a les noirs de Maxime
nul c'est pas mal
nul c'est sympa c'est un bon résultat
alors comment on peut faire ici est-ce
qu'on ramène notre cavalier aussi
c'est le Google
le premier tour de Maxime
je pense que Maxime a assez largement
favori mais attention
attention à la jeune star montante
des échecs mondiaux
mais Maxime a trop d'expérience et ça y
est c'est parti
mvl Diniz
qui se balade
ça y est ça y est ça y est c'est parti
c'est parti pour la balade on le suit
on les plie
et on le voit passer
on le peut le deviner derrière
sa position
il est content
on adore le suivre ensuite notre
champion
regardez-moi ça
j'adore très fan bon allez on va
regarder avec Christina quand même
la régie est incroyable merci elle est
ça va c'est pas
c'est un peu une escroquerie ce que je
suis en train de vous faire je suis en
train de vous faire croire je suis bon
alors que franchement c'est c'est quand
même c'est quand même assez simple alors
Maxime qui a peut-être sera soit
attention à ce qui avait lieu trois
c'est un peu
c'est un petit peu désagréable quand
même
et on le suit mvl
il est là
il fait ça tout le temps
un magicien ne révèle pas ses secrets
tout à fait exact
Berty axe
alors comment on fait je sais pas je
sais pas ce que je ferais je crois qu'on
est obligé de filer un fou quand même
c'est un peu désagréable ça m'étonne pas
qu'il réfléchisse il joue faut aussi en
prévention ok cavalier
3 OK et maintenant il va faire quel est
G4 clairement
comment fait-on maintenant
pour ne pas perdre ce fou pour pas de
voir par le perdre mais si vous voulez
de voir les changer
ouais
non en fait je crois pas alors à la
question question là
dans les parties je crois pas si il y a
un coup illégal de jouer si votre
adversaire le voit pas c'est bon ça
continue
je crois qu'on a 5 coups pour ça
apercevoir je crois que l'arbitre a pas
intervenir
je sais pas
je crois qu'il doit pas intervenir s'il
le voit mais bon normalement les
arbitres ils connaissent pas les règles
donc ils vont pas le voir le coup
illégal
donc si ton adversaire le voit pas
terminé il ne voit pas non plus vous
avez fini on fait ça compte
je suis pas sûr honnêtement les règles
changent en fait
c'est ça aussi le truc méchant les
règles changent
régulièrement
on balance les arbitres
maintenant arbitre c'est tout intervenir
je crois ouais mais moi je balance sur
les arbitres
c'est quand même c'est quand même c'est
populaire de balancer sur les arbitres
qui n'a jamais une embrouille avec un
arbitre
il me jette la pierre
qu'est-ce qui est fini un coup de légal
bah c'est un coup tu laisses ton roi en
échec
[Musique]
des choses comme ça écoute pas le droit
de jouer tu mets ton fou de eux deux en
C5 voilà c'est ça qui est égal
c'est un coup interdit par les règles du
jeu
kic4 ici est très mauvais mais c'est pas
illégal puis on prend voilà c'est ça la
différence
et qui est C8 ça ça dépend chacun décide
trois fois même position machin là
échiquiers s'il y avait une
retransmission mais c'était pas très
clair si ça faisait foi ou pas si la
retransmission se faisait foi pour les
réclamations de trois fois la même
position
donc mais j'ai pas en l'occurrence
c'était pas une envoyer la vie c'est une
embrouille avec le avec le joueur
alors
le cavalier en 7 et en F5 c'est pas mal
son truc j'aime bien
un peu très solide un peu légèrement
passif je dirais certaines
certaines mauvaises langues mais quand
même c'est pas mal
c'est pas facile le Berlin
ces quatre saisons ça va être le seul
plan maintenant pour améliorer la
position vous voyez
toutes les pièces sont hyper bien
placées
quasiment maximal
quasiment maximum mais
la seule moyen il y a quand même pas de
faiblesse chinois donc le seul moyen de
d'accentuer cette pression ça va être un
moment de jouer un coup comme C4 mais ça
correspondable pourquoi parce que ça
crée aussi des équilibres peut-être un
pion faible donc il faut faire attention
il faut faire attention
pourquoi les joueurs notent-ils ou non
les coups on n'est pas obligé de noter
en partie rapide c'est-à-dire en moins
de c'est à partir de 50 + 10 on est
obligé de noter
mais sinon partie plus rapide on n'est
pas obligé de noter on peut on a le
droit mais
on le fait pas
il avait raison mais il a fait il a mal
fait il a joué son coup il a appuyé sur
un pendule et donc il avait il avait
tort sur le
vice de procédure il avait raison sur le
sur le fond c'est bien trois fois ce
dont j'étais pas sûr
mais en vrai il joue son cou il a plu
donc il fait n'importe quoi en fait il
faut appeler arbitre d'abord faut
arrêter la pendule et dire quel con on
va jouer
n'importe quoi donc l'arbitre refuse
la le truc et quand je te dis bah si
c'est comme ça j'arrête le tournoi
et donc ça aurait suivi une demi-heure
discussion
invitation quand même
[Musique]
voilà bon ben j'ai fait un effort j'ai
fait nul j'ai gagné la partie d'après
ah c'était génial moi je voulais pas me
lâcher et puis bon au final j'ai lâché
là je suis finalement
il était encore ténieux comme c'était un
gamin quoi c'était vraiment
quoi si c'est pas comme ça j'arrête
voilà c'est vraiment c'est un gamin de
10 ans quoi c'est incroyable
très peu de gens non mais je plaisante
j'adore j'ai des amis arbitres ne
t'inquiète pas un free bird je plaisante
sur les arbitres après il y a des
mauvais aussi mais il y a des bons comme
partout en fait il y a des bons et des
mauvais chasseurs et il y a des bons et
des mauvaises arbitres
ambulance les amis j'ai un ami ah
arbitre
non
j'ai quelques non non j'aime bien les
arbres il y a des arbitres qui sont bons
pas tous
partout c'est comme partout voilà
il y a pas de bon chasseur c'est vrai
alors cavaliers
donc on l'avait prévu ce coup de C4 qui
a eu le 7 il joue très solide à faire
pousser cette il veut certainement
mettre quelque chose en F5 il est quand
même pas mal
notre ami je vais mettre je reviens
je vous la fenêtre il fait 200 degrés
ici et oui bienvenue à Paris on est bien
on fait 200 degrés il y a pas d'air et
quand on ouvre la fenêtre et bien il y a
un bruit de perceuse c'est génial on
adore
alors quel est le 7 il fait C5 Maxime ah
là il commence à montrer à montrer les
muscles à prendre des petits risques
il déséquilibre tout ça il s'est quand
même créer une petite faiblesse mine de
rien alors elle est pas facile à
attaquer tout ça il veut faire fouder 6
il essaie de mettre la pression il est
moins bien en temps aussi 16 minutes
compte 13 ça crée Maxime qui veut
vraiment essayer de gagner cette partie
et en finir avec ce tournoi valider sa
victoire dans ce tournoi en grosse
confiance
ça a été une mission 7 4 et demi sur 5
sur la dernière partie bon ben
effectivement ça donne la confiance
c'est pas c'est assez légitime et joue
KSG penthala
attaque le fou on veut prendre la paire
de fou aussi la jauge n'aime pas
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire fout des 6
fautes je suppose fou 7 quoi que quoi
que fausses 7 je peux prendre peut-être
prendre ici
ou prendre ici d'abord qu'est-ce que ça
donne elle aime pas la jauge mais
admettons ce genre de position qui est
mieux et pourquoi le fouet pas terrible
mais quoique ça peut arriver vite ce
genre de choses
alors on va voir ce qu'il va faire il
faut des six mvl
et on va voir ce que fait penthalass qui
fait fausse il va faire tourner
et tu as envie de jouer
on s'en doutait
ou c'est une gaffe c'est une gaffe ça
pourrait être bouclé c'est quoi c'est F4
le coup est-ce que c'est F4 le coup
menace f5f4 le coup il est facile à voir
celui-là on la gaffe sur F5 ok prep 5
petite forme de penthala F4 attention et
sur cavalier 7 par exemple qui
protégerait F50
on a deux deux gars là on a tout reprend
8 fois qu'il y a mais on a [__] F5
encore plus fort pour prendre
intermédiaire d'un et d'un prime 5 et
dame 8 échec et mat
oh il a pas joué il a joué kf5 quel
dommage
oh là là là là F4 c'était terminé
oh là là là là là
dommage F4 F4 c'était la fin du tournoi
F4 pour faire F5 dans d'autres
conditions il l'aurait vu Maxime parce
que c'est dommage
cavalier F5 ok il est toujours bien de
toute façon ça c'est sûr sur foo.fr ça
va pas du tout on a tout prend
c'est toujours mat ça met un coup de
plus mais c'est maintenant quand même
donc comment on fait ici il avait le
temps ouais mais bon il peut pas savoir
aussi des sites de jouer vite c'est ça
l'inconvénient et joue vite
aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe pourquoi j'ai vu un
tempo c'est très simple parce que la
jauge elle fait elle fait
elle fait un bon c'est ce qu'avait dit
ah non à l'époque juste ça pendant les
parties de savoir l'évaluation c'est une
aide incroyable vous voyez rien que ça
donc c'est pour ça que
[Musique]
il faut il faut prendre au sérieux ce ce
problème alors là il y a pas de
évidemment
qui se passe mais ce problème de la
triche parce que ça peut être même par
moment
juste une petite indication si on vient
vous taper sur l'épaule en vous disant
ah ben là tu as un coup gagnant et bien
c'est une aide incroyable
et à Nantes ça avait parlé il y a très
très longtemps alors comment on fait
maintenant sur kf5 le problème de Key F5
c'est qu'il y a pas de menace l'avantage
de F4 c'était qu'il y avait une énorme
menace avec F5
ouais tu sais qu'il faut chercher
exactement c'est ça le truc tu sais
qu'il faut chercher ça fait un écart
c'est c'est délire
alors foie F6 ok il se replace
sur ça ah faut pas la perdre quand même
ça serait important
ça serait important je sais pas s'il a
accès après aux Eva entre les parties
mais ça pourrait faire mal ça pourrait
faire mal d'avoir un truc là
ouais c'est ça et tu sais quand il ne
faut pas chercher surtout effectivement
donc c'est pour ça que même ça c'est une
aide incroyable en fait de connaître
l'évaluation je pense si on connaît
l'évaluation
en toute la partie on prend je sais pas
on gagne tous 200 points ou je sais pas
en fait je sais pas je sais pas quand il
fait mais on gagne beaucoup et ça c'est
sûr
donc fu F6 en plus on se donne une case
pour la dame c'est pas mal son coup de
fou F6 oh la pentala il avait
complètement raté
ouais non
si mais même ceux qui comprennent pas ça
ils doivent pas savoir aux échecs ici
ils comprennent les gens faut pas tout
le monde comprend parce que c'est à tous
les niveaux parce qu'en fait même si on
a 900 si on dit il y a une tactique et
bien on a beaucoup plus de chance de la
trouver donc ça c'est vraiment
je salue tous les joueurs à 900 dans ce
chat et je leur souhaite la bienvenue
parce que tout le monde a le droit de
s'amuser moi-même je les ai oubli
d'autres vies voilà c'est normal et donc
on a tous été débutant un jour ça faut
jamais oublier faut jamais oublier qu'on
ait tout et en plus on est tous le
débutant de quelqu'un même Magnus et le
débutant de stockfish donc voilà
l'important c'est de prendre du plaisir
et même même c'était un peu
désobligeants ce que je disais mais
voilà mais même un joueur débutant en
fait si on lui tape sur l'épaule et si
on lui dit il y a un truc à trouver il a
beaucoup plus de chance de trouver c'est
évident
c'est tout le monde le comprend ça en
fait
c'est pour ça qu'à mon avis c'est un
meilleur entraînement de regarder les
parties en direct que de faire des
exercices tout simplement parce que
quand on regarde les parties en direct
sans la jauge évidemment
et bien on sait pas s'il y a quelque
chose à trouver ou pas
alors que j'ai trois jouets par mvl sur
la petite tactique
et on va récupérer le fou donc c'est pas
vraiment pris c'est un pseudo sacrifice
et il veut faire cavalier H5 le coup du
retour
est-ce que sur food 8 il y a F4 ou pas
et F4 encore une fois est-ce qu'il
l'aurait vu Maxime
est-ce qu'il aurait vu fou H4 là c'est
un peu plus compliqué mais je crois que
ça marche pas et ouais 5 et surtout
prends G3 en fait c'est pas tellement
plus compliqué ce que je prends ici ça
ça gagne aussi je pense que ça gagne
facilement
à cause de ça tout simplement pour
prendre un prank prendre à gagner une
pièce
donc attention est-ce qu'il s'est rendu
compte de son erreur Maxime pas
impossible
et comment jouer ici avec les Noirs il
s'est mis dans le il s'est mis dans le
dur quand même avec les chiens pas si
facile que ça à jouer cette position et
surtout ce F4 qui est dans l'air
clairement
attention les maths du couloir qui
traînent
j'en ai déjà parlé de mes matchs de mes
différents matchs 87
j'en ai déjà parlé de mes matchs contre
Amazon au championnat de France en
Championship tour aussi moi je vois ça
comme un ensemble c'est match alignation
directe
où j'ai joué trois tournois coup sur
coup c'était de l'élimination directe
et
voilà bon c'est décevant globalement
qu'est-ce que je te dise
c'est comme ça si c'est une gaffe
c'est une gaffe
c'est une gaffe à cause de F4
non
Maxime allez F4 allez F4 F4 pour jouer
F5 quand même
One Time Is You cahier
c'est l'enfer
il y a du marteau derrière moi je vais
refermer bientôt
ne t'inquiète pas
est-ce que je peux mettre à la place des
joueurs je peux tout faire je peux
mettre au milieu des chéquier même si
j'ai envie
oh là là
mais bon F4 ouais je sais pas pourquoi
il joue pas je sais pas ce qu'il arrête
là parce que c'est sûr qu'il a envisagé
en fait qu'est-ce qu'il y a
je comprends pas ce qu'il arrête
mais c'est sur échec pardon
en fait est tellement imparable il a pas
la rêve de F5 apparemment
ça c'est une boucherie
on peut même faire fou prends ouais faut
prendre
ton repas 8
voilà c'est dommage mais bon il avait la
rêve de cavalier H5 qui menaçait sur
Fougères 5 il veut faire F4 évidemment
qu'est-ce qui joue la récré est-ce que
vous prend des quatre est bon vous
rangez si ça perd terrible vous rangez 6
puis on prend G6 non il y a mieux que ça
il y a mieux que ça d'après la jauge
c'est quoi mieux que ça
il y aura pas de casse pour le fou donc
faut bien un truc comme ça
il y a pas de casse pour le fou c'est un
désastre on est obligé de revenir par là
et on peut prendre et prendre là-bas ou
prendre là-bas pour le spectacle mais
c'est moins bon c'est moins bon à mon
avis c'est pas bon du tout c'est 3
attaque la tour menace la dame non non
on fait pas le spectacle en tout cas il
prime puis on prend et dame prend
en bon père de famille on fait ça
alors qu'il voyage 5 ah mais moi je
serai plutôt c'est un jeu hein
moi je suis plutôt
il préfère il préfère la jauge
pour les parties rapides je suis plus
pour la jauge honnêtement pour les
parties rapides et les Blitz je trouve
ça sympa d'avoir la jauge ça peut aller
vite et tout ça pour les parties
classiques je pense que c'est mieux sans
la jauge honnêtement c'était le parti
qu'on avait pris sur chaise 24 donc vous
voyez ici c'est pareil je sais pas si
pour les parties longs je crois qu'il
met de la jauge aussi mais en tout cas
pour les rapides on a quand même pris ce
parti là
alors caillage 5
il est pas père de famille non euh
mais il peut jouer il peut parfois jouer
c'est rare
le coup du bon père de famille qui
coupent
exactement Tortue Géniale tout à fait
qu'est-ce qu'il a joué il réfléchit 9 30
contre 8,30
et je sais pas c'est trop ce qu'il doit
faire ça c'est moche ça
c'est apparemment le coup de la jauge ça
en fait
OK
pas si mauvais et ensuite on menace web
ouais si c'est un mauvais coup si tu
vois pas F4 en fait
il va faire 7 penthala parce que fout
des 8 est trop passif je crois qu'on va
retomber dans les on entend pas d'un F4
là on retourne à F4 les magnifiques F4
non on peut pas on peut pas jouer comme
ça il va jouer
c'est évident qu'il va faire fausse
cette
faut prendre des quatre foulées quand
même pas très dur à voir je sais pas
quoi il réfléchit en fait honnêtement
honnêtement
honnêtement je vois pas pourquoi il
réfléchit non car ça ne joue pas ce
tournoi ni Nakamura ils peuvent pas être
partout fautes 4 jouets ça c'est
surprenant
parce que ça fait rien faut acheter
alors c'est un coup surprenant certes
mais ça menace rien et quand même les
pièces blanches sont très bien placées
il faut éliminer ce fou c'est clair
alors comment on fait pour accentuer
cette pression
il veut provoquer j'ai trois clairement
on va pas faire G3 quoi c'est pas si mal
faut acheter j'aime bien finalement
mais quel est le prochain coup des Noirs
peut-être ça
ok
c'est bien de comprendre les menaces
c'est important de comprendre la menace
de votre adversaire parce que
franchement
ça permet de l'empêcher ou alors de
décider que on le laisse faire
mais en toute conscience
F4 il y a quoi il faut prendre
c'est pour ça que je voulais peut-être
bouger la tour pour menacer F4 mais je
sais pas finalement j'aime pas trop on a
envie de dire oust au fou
intéressant
je sais pas ce qu'on doit faire
et Maxime en plus ok je sais pas ce que
je jouerais ici
très honnêtement des idées
rouages 2 mais bon
[Musique]
bravo
bravo cherie
F4 quand même
j'espérais je misais tout sur F4
il va nous jouer CE2 ou pas
et dame c'est deux bravo à trouver le
coup de mvl c'est pas donné à tout le
monde
n'est pas une menace pour l'instant
c'est vrai
plus tard empêche aussi des fougères
même si F4 et renforce la case F5 et
menace vous prend G6 donc il va falloir
faire quelque chose sur ce foot ranger 6
et oui le chatouilleur le chatouilleur
Maxime vacherin grave qui pose une
question et c'est toujours bien de poser
une question par contre il est moins
bien au temps alors ça c'est quand même
une surprise
mais j'adore comment il gère son temps
dans ce tournoi il réfléchit quand il
faut voilà tout simplement roi H7 on
n'aime pas roi L7 on se met dans le
couloir on se fait pas ça ne faites pas
ça jamais vous voyez la jauge elle a pas
aimé mais c'est pas étonnant par exemple
pas du tout sur le champ je pensais que
c'était un bon coup mais ça ne l'est pas
quel est le coup ici
je sais pas peut-être
ouais mais le problème c'est que c'est
le
c'est le coup à jeternel c'est ça donc
ça ça va pas donc est-ce qu'il va faire
il va certainement jouer un coup de
cavalier alors cavalier fuit tout
cavalier 7 mais en vrai cavalier par
exemple tout bête comme ça je me pose
pas trop de questions bah voilà
maintenant bonne chance à toi cher ami
comment tu protèges G7 F6 c'est un coup
quand on préfère préfère pas le faire
mais on va pas avoir trop le choix donc
c'est c'est très compliqué là
alors
c'est pas bon mais je sais pas ce qu'il
va faire peut-être cavalier à fuite
pour au moins mais bon
et non apparemment c'est pas du tout
pénible c'est pas bon faut 5 pas bon du
tout creuset
pourquoi il aime pas j'en sais rien
je triche
Dame des deux
coups
pourquoi ça perd je vais vous le montrer
tu reprends le huit dame prend 8 vous
prend F5 il veut dame
F2 et là il a raté
il a raté
allez Maxime
allez Maxime il va nous le jouer il va
nous le jouer
tour reprend et
alors pas trois fois c'est vrai
c'est pas tendu du tout
c'est pas tendu du tout c'est facile il
faut prendre
a été joué dame prend fou prends d'amour
rouage de fou point F2 c'est jouer il
faut prendre F5 damer 3 2 et là
maintenant on va se faire la vue du
dessus et on va voir la tête de la
Krishna
on va attendre un peu parce que je suis
pas sûr d'être sur la cam4 sur l'autre
et [__] F2 il vient de voir
Maxime va chier la grave
et on va se mettre on a la vue du dessus
et je me mets là allez hop je me mets là
pour contempler la mine
oh là là regardez-moi ça
la mine déconfite de la Krishna
c'est complètement terminé la jouer il a
joué Dumber évidemment faut prendre a
été joué et dame a été joué et ce qu'il
avait pas vu avec ça c'est qu'il pensait
menacé maths il pensait que c'était
imparable il pensait qu'on pouvait pas
prendre de fou mais il a pas vu d'un et
c'est terminé
ado Maxime Vacher la grave au minimum au
minimum premier execo je vais regarder
tout de suite sur mon téléphone ce qui
se passe dans la partie de rajabov on
reste sur ça évidemment pour l'instant
il est parti de rajabov et bien c'est
égal pour le moment c'est une filiale de
tout il a un pion noir à jabov je crois
qu'on peut
quasiment officialiser la victoire de
Maxime vachergrave dans ce droit de
partir rapide du tata style India ça
sera beau c'est beau il a un pion de
plus et Regamey il peut plus la perdre
la finale de tour donc maintenant il
faut que Maxime termine notre travail
mais ça a été rendement mené cette
histoire
pas de jeans du de la personne oh là là
il se repose jamais
j'en peux plus je vais gueuler la
fenêtre
vous serez content oh là là l'enfer
l'enfer qu'est-ce qu'il fait il coupe
toujours la même planche au type j'ai
jamais vu ça
je n'ai jamais vu ça
ouais c'est pas fini mais quand même
personne de 5 quoi c'est ça perceuse de
5 le type coupe la même planche depuis
trois jours
forcement on se demande ce qu'il fait
pourquoi et pourquoi non non c'est pas
une grosse planche je l'ai vu elle fait
genre elle fait 1 m 50 elle fait de de
la chaise là
au bout du truc enfin je veux dire elle
fait un mètre 50 de mètres max
si je suis une machine
type le plus lent de l'histoire du BTP
non c'est une toute petite planche
incroyable
ouais c'est possible que je m'énerve
vraiment qu'est-ce qu'il fait il joue
dame de
attention attaque le cavalier on se
reconcentre c'est bien ça passe ces
histoires
qu'est-ce que c'est que ce coup
et sur foutrange ici il fait quoi il
fait quoi
il fait quoi sur vous projet 6 il fait
quoi
il fait quoi il plaisante ou quoi
puis on prend les 6 dames prends G6
attention quand même j'ai une petite
menace pas facile à apparaît
certainement vous prend des drive donc
bon ouais c'est une pièce alors après
faut faire attention à Madame et ce
genre d'histoire ça c'est vrai mais
quand même
alors peut-être qu'il y a mieux que ça
encore il y a un fichier en tout cas
Maxime
il a bien raison 4,50 contre 4,20
on n'est pas hyper inquiet
alors j'ai une idée pour finir en style
si je prends prends
H5 ça finit pas du tout en style
non ça ça va pas aller peut-être qu'on
peut garder le foot peut-être qu'il a
raison Maxime peut-être fouger 4 attaque
la dame et ensuite dame F5 quelque chose
comme ça non la chose j'aime pas du tout
bon vas-y on va jouer on va jouer quand
même on va arrêter de plaisanter là
arrêtez de présenter deux secondes
cette dame G4 petit coup de vis là
très très malhonnête
et attention attaque le fou aussi
attention on peut avoir ça aussi
ouais non ça c'est complètement gagnant
clairement
c'est complètement gagnant
cavalier F4 au lieu d'un projet 6 est
très très bien aussi très bien vu
trois
et quoi
les quatre quand même mais bon c'est de
toute façon ouais c'est de toute façon
archi gagnant de plusieurs manières
différentes il essaie il veut terminer
le travail
un maximum un peu nerveux quand même qui
réfléchit mais bon une pièce de plus
donc il peut être un peu nerveux il
réfléchit veut terminer tout de suite
ah oui ça c'est ce qui me plaît le plus
pour l'instant
attaque la dame et attention dame aussi
ce pour échanger les dames mdr
et ouais mais là on échange pas les
dames attention va y avoir des échecs
non moins fan
il a joué 3 ml
OK
inattendu
que j'ai trois dmd2 jouer je sais pas ce
qu'il va encaisser à la F50 ensuite
il prend
qu'est-ce qu'il fait là qu'est-ce qui se
passe sur
sur
6 on va menacer chaque email
peut-être pas mal ça
ouais ça ça ressemble au coup du pro
photographe qui marche sur les pieds là
voilà
alors
faut 5 le coup du pro on donne pas des
cas on donne des quatre mais en échange
à ce moment-là
quoi pas vraiment en fait parce qu'on
peut pas en prendre ce puret avec
cavalier F5 et c'est terminé
alors
faut 5 et maintenant comment on fait
on fait rien on est foutu
attention attention à Christian parce
qu'il est très
peu trouvé il peut trouver des
ressources cavaliers
attaque la dame
où est-ce qu'on va dame a priori
quoi d'autre
dame de jouer
et maintenant comment on fait pour
avancer avec les Blancs moi une pièce de
plus simple c'est sûr mais bon
pas fini
pas fini du tout
ouais
pourquoi pas et joue normalement avec
une pièce de plus mais ça aurait pu être
plus convaincant la finition a pas été
parfaite
alors
B4 qu'est-ce qu'il va faire
250 contre 3 minutes
B4 il a joué à 6 tout simplement bon à 4
le coup
ouais le cavalier ouais c'est quand même
c'est quand même il fait à trois pour
protéger son pion OK
ça c'est le truc le plus solide et
ensuite un moment ou un autre je sais
pas ce qui va être obligé de revenir et
le cavalier en G3
essayer de progresser d'une manière ou
d'une autre
de 40 pour à Krishna et ça pourrait se
terminer maintenant que fait notre Amir
à jabov un Jobo toujours en défense dans
cette filière de tour mais le tour pour
probablement nul donc attention si
Maxime ne gagne pas cette partie ça peut
être la dernière honte de la peur
de la peur c'est à dire avec
mvl à portée de tir c'est-à-dire un
point d'avance mais les Noirs contre
Raja bof donc ça serait beaucoup mieux
de gagner
allez
allez allez allez
qu'est-ce qu'il a joué il a joué
Fouin que j'ai 3 dame 3
et maintenant Maxime un tout petit peu
qu'est-ce qu'on menace c'est pas clair
est-ce que on ferait pas un petit coup
de dame D1 là
pour se repositionner la dame un petit
peu mais le roi est assez safe quoi que
Dame de la meuf 3 donc c'est sûr c'est
complètement gagnant pour les blancs il
y a même pas de question
quelque chose comme ça alors c'est ça
on force la dame à revenir et ensuite on
encaisse les pions en plus c'est vrai
ok intéressant
alors pardon
qu'est-ce qu'il a joué là ouais
envie de mettre ses pièces en prison
c'est pas le moment
merci no brain no gains c'est demain les
Blitz le tournoi de partir rapide se
termine ce soir demain Blitz 11h30
jusqu'à attends il y a 9 ans par jour
donc ça va durer ça va durer en faut
compter une demi-heure par Blitz
donc
moi 4h30 10 par jour et peut-être
doubler pour mvl fève de jouer comme ça
sur dame F3 et la dame heure
c'est bien vu il pose encore les
derniers problèmes à Krishna
je suis au commentaire tout le tournoi
tout à fait
jusqu'au bout je lâche plus j'ai tout
mis en place
honnêtement je serais pas embêté parce
que quand même faut pas se plaindre avec
une pièce de plus mais
il est plus simple et plus simple c'est
sûr là par exemple on commence à avoir
des échecs revient comment savoir des
plus ou moins des petites menaces quoi
ça s'appelle pas une menace dame de pair
dame 2 ouh là là la gaffe ce serait la
gaffe du genre français ça serait un
désastre en G3 échec vous prend et
d’âmes brandables attention il est
jamais trop tard pour faire une partie
de chaque cavalier a changé ou que c'est
bien joué ou que c'est bien joué alors
je me remets là
complètement obligé
il est obligé à Krishna il va le jouer
parce qu'il va le comprendre qu'il est
obligé
peut-être peut-être que c'est ça l'idée
j'aime pas quand même on a réussi à
mettre nos même ça est-ce que c'est si
facile que ça pour les blancs je trouve
ça devient de moins en moins facile bon
on va voir combien il a fait un maximum
une 39 contre 50 secondes
la peur de gagner peut-être un peu ouais
peut-être un peu
fou hein
c'est possible qu'ils veuille ça ah oui
ça exactement
à mon avis
7 est-ce que ça forcerait pas l'abandon
tout ça
est-ce que ça forcerait pas l'abandon
ouais ouais ouais ouais je crois que
c'est gagné on applaudit
on applaudit quand il abandonne on est
d'accord
H5
mon garçon
ça a quand même pas être terrible
voilà c'est trop facile même promesses
en fait hein
Maxime Vacher la grave
c'est ça
c'est lui ça
j'ai 5 même
la finale a gagné ok j'ai trois
et j'ai trois va être joué évidemment
évidemment que kéké G3 a été joué par
mvl menace cavalier F5 menace qui prend
H5 c'est complètement terminé on va
assister à un abandon de Harry Krishna
et Maxime attends que ça
et ça boude ça abandonne pas bien
oh regardez moi ça regardez moi oh là là
c'est bon on adore
on adore quand c'est mauvais comme ça
ok prends le 5 quelle tactique bravo
Maxime Acher La Grave grand tacticien
sida prend 5 dame prend G7 et surpris on
prend H3 on va jouer le coup du pro dame
prend G7 d'un projet 7 qui prend les 7
pièces et puis en plus bravo Maxime
vainqueur du tournoi a priori on va voir
s'il y aura déjà bof
fait mieux ou pas il est au Raja bof il
est là
donc c'est pas gagné à mon avis
bravo à lui
et ça fait vraiment plaisir
[Musique]
on va voir la partie de Raja bof pour
que ce soit officiel tout ça
et ça a proposé nul c'est très officiel
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé on voit les
rois au milieu ok on va essayer de
regarder une partie Google je prends un
assez sympa aussi on va aller voir ça
même ça joue pour du beurre Maxime va
chier La Grave et le vainqueur du
tournoi rapide
de
tata style India 2023 Google
qu'est-ce qui nous reste comme partie
dites-moi n'hésitez pas on a visite
gamer
on va aller voir quelque chose c'est mon
c'est mon bref
vous savez
alors petit gris de
on a cette position 19 secondes bon ben
ça c'est normal contrat d'où ça torov
position finale plus ou moins égal
bravo
bravo à en tout cas à Maxime ma chère
regardez on va finaliser ça Maxime
Vacher la grappe si c'est une mission 8
5 sur 8 pour un jobov c'est fini plus
être attrapé on va regarder ça non
qu'est-ce que j'ai fait non ça on va
changer ça on va changer ça pour
pour regarder ce qu'on va mettre
vainqueur on va se faire plaisir on va
se faire plaisir vainqueur
voilà voilà si c'est demi sur 8 on reste
évidemment pour garder la dernière nous
on joue pour du beurre les derniers vous
savez on gagne avant on gagne avant la
dernière onde ça c'est la c'est la
french touch
vainqueur Maxime va chier La Grave et
oui et oui et oui oui si c'est une
mission 8 hauteur d'un tournoi XXL tout
simplement
tout simplement il vient d'enchaîner un
5 et demi sur 6
incroyable
il gagne combien que se tourne on sait
pas on sait pas Tortue Génial pour la
gloire nous
c'est pour la confiance c'est important
avance ces grosses échéances de fin
d'année notamment
l'île de Man mais il y a des bons prix
vous en faites pas pour eux
et qu'est-ce qu'il y a eu nulle entre
Alexander greachuk et nordy Beck à torov
alors qu'est-ce qui se passe ailleurs
on a gamer gamer et
visite qui joue
un peu un peu un peu en difficulté
clairement dans le tournoi voir beaucoup
mais par rapport à leur standing et
leurs espérances mais ça se bat jusqu'au
bout vous inquiétez pas sortez mieux
comme tous les deux
alors comment il joue vite il y a
beaucoup de pions là pour la qualité
ça pousse dans tous les sens pauvre
gamer et encore se prendre une bulle
et encore se prendre une bulle j'ai
l'impression
comment ça se passe le mindset de mvel
sur la dernière il va jouer des tentes
il va jouer enfin il a les Noirs contre
un rajabov donc nul ça va mais en vrai
il va la jouer cette partie on a gagné
le Torah il est content il est là ça va
jouer vite à mon avis et ça va faire du
mvl du Maxime Diniz tu vois ce que je
veux dire ça je vais vite ça va se lever
mais ça va jouer quand même ça va
réfléchir quand il y a besoin de
réfléchir c'est important de pas casser
la confiance aussi
donc important tout ça
alors bref trois le roi entre 3 cases et
on menace de pousser on menace de
pousser je sais pas
salut j'ai pas eu le temps tout à
l'heure j'ai vu je crois que Yoshi
mettait j'ai vu Yoshi apparaître salut à
toi iOS
[Musique]
il y a eu qui a paru au meilleur moment
quand mvl a finalisé cette victoire
ouais j'étais pas sûr dans le dans le
flot des messages et du coup même c'est
ce qui m'avait semblé belle victoire de
Maxime va chier La Grave magnifique ça
fait plaisir ça fait plaisir en retour
comme ça alors effectivement
ça compte pas pour aller au classique
déjà ça compte pour les lots rapides on
va aller faire un petit tour tiens
peut-être sur le hello rapide il va
peut-être repasser en top 3 mondial
c'est ce qu'on disait docteur ville
basse tout à l'heure
mais
oh il a pas vu que c'est 8 obstruction
obstruction oh là il y aura tout gamer
dans ce tournoi oh c'est l'enfer ah ça
devient gênant
il y aura tout regardez sa tête à chaque
fois il en peut plus il n'en peut plus
abondant
avant donc c'est lui de la prise de la
dame moi j'aime pas
ouais c'est un truc c'est un truc pas
très agréable parce qu'on sait que
l'adversaire va abandonner
ouais non
pas faire play j'aime pas ça ouais donc
mvl qui se remet bien en confiance et
donc c'est important c'est ça ne
s'achète pas la confiance et ce que je
dis depuis depuis deux jours il sort
quand même d'une période assez difficile
clairement avec la Coupe du Monde qui
est pas du tout revenu
remettre cette confiance
donc
il faut se boost de confiance avant
avant c'est clair les résultats de la
ronde
que tu au cap de
gamme Victor vide Google
face à un Krishna
qui lui a fait une belle Master Class
sur une tour humberlinoise qui a eu
trois chances qui a saisi la troisième
bravo à lui et qui gagne le tournoi car
et
nul contre
Raja bof
résultat les infos sur le second de mvl
puis 351 on a parlé depuis ce tout à
l'heure c'est Laurent Blanc le nouvel
entraîneur
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qu'il va faire il va essayer
de forcer une nulle on le connaît entre
tes mots pour assurer un deuxième place
c'est tout lui ça bon on va voir on va
voir ce qui se passe mais toute façon on
reste et pour ce
pour ceux on va se regarder les les déjà
les appareils de la dernière onde je
vous mets ça en direct pour ceux que ça
intéresse pas allez pour ceux qui se
disent c'est gagné après avoir demain il
y a les Blitz à 11h30 donc je reprendrai
l'antenne vers 11h20 quelque chose comme
ça donc n'hésitez pas à nous rejoindre
mais on prend les mêmes on recommence
mais on repart à zéro on a Raja Bofa
chez Lagrave dans cette dernière onde de
notre beau match Prague et easy de toute
façon ils se battent comme des
chiffonniers les jeunes joueurs indiens
donc il y a vraiment aucun problème sur
le suspense la prochaine ronde
normalement et dans 18 minutes je fais
une petite pause
je fais une petite pause quand même
parce que il fait chaud il fait chaud je
vais prendre l'air je vais essayer
d'ouvrir la fenêtre pour voir si notre
ami du BTP est encore en train de
travailler on en peut plus de lui
petite pause et je reviens pour
commenter cette dernière partie avec un
Raja bof mvl de gala voilà on reste
ensemble pour fêter pour fêter cette
victoire ensemble voilà pour être de
bonne humeur et de voir tout ça et
encore une fois
bravo à Maxime ma chérie qui gagne le
tournoi avec le tour de partir rapide en
tout cas on verra pour le Blitz mais ça
sent bon aussi mais ça a pas encore
commencé ça sent déjà bon ça sent ça
sent déjà bon donc il gagne le tournoi
de partir rapide avec une ronde d'avance
bravo bravo et à tout de suite on se
retrouve dans quelques petites minutes
merci infiniment de me suivre
quel est le meilleur moyen de suivre
n'importe quel événement échiquier
surpris a du monde au tournoi des
candidats en passant par le speechess ou
les title
tussday.com/avent scoop tous les plus
grands tournois d'échec il se déroule en
présentiel ou en ligne vivez comprenez
en direct les parties des meilleurs
joueurs de la planète avec les
commentaires en français de nos experts
notre moteur d'analyse l'explorateur
d'ouverture et les tables bases
retrouvez toutes les infos essentielles
comme le programme les horaires des
rondes les prix les résultats les
comptes rendus quotidien les bio des
joueurs les règles des partages et plus
encore vous pouvez même participer à la
compétition en pronostiquant les
résultats pour tenter de gagner des
abonnements premium alors rendez-vous
dès maintenant sur chess.com/avent ou
c'est bien sur le site internet que sur
nos applications iOS et Android pour
vivre votre passion comme nulle part
ailleurs
[Musique]
et je suis de retour pour cette dernière
ronde du tournoi rapide du stata style
chasing dia rapides
qui compte entre guillemets pour du
beurre dans la victoire finale pourquoi
parce que Maxime va chez La Grave
l'emporter bravo à lui déjà si c'est une
mission 8 et il est complètement
il rattrapable sur le point vue sur le
point de vue d'un point de vue
mathématique et oui pas besoin d'avoir
fait pas besoin d'avoir fait des études
de mathématiques comme Maxime
pour comprendre qu'avec un point
évidemment c'est une ronde à jouer et
bien c'est gagné
un point et demi d'avance sur son
adversaire de la dernière ronde Témo
Raja BOV deux points d'avance sur Google
visite Abdou Sator 3 points et demi
d'avance sur airigazic 4 points d'avance
sur Vincent gamer et 4 points et demi
d'avance sur Harry Krishna quand c'est
dit comme ça c'est vrai que c'est c'est
large c'est vraiment très très
impressionnant on va voir la dernière
ronde donc tu es Morad jabov face à mvl
on a des beaux appareils il y a des il y
a des supers appareils évidemment demain
dès demain on prend les mêmes et on
recommence on va se mettre sur la partie
de
Maxime évidemment pour suivre cette
partie honnêtement
c'est possible on tourne l'échiquier
évidemment c'est possible qu'il y aura
déjà bof tente essaye de faire une nulle
rapide
pourquoi parce que ça arrangerait bien
Raja BOV de pas jouer l'homme
en super forme de ce tournoi celui qui a
dominé de la tête et les épaules se
tournoi nulle il garantit la deuxième
place au moins execo c'est plutôt une
bonne affaire
est-ce que Maxime avec les noirs a
plutôt un répertoire solide on va voir à
voir à voir tout ça on va suivre ça
évidemment
pour voir ce que ça donne sur cette
dernière ronde je serais bien allé faire
un tour du côté de 2700 chess pour voir
est-ce que je peux vous le montrer
est-ce que vous allez le voir
est-ce que vous allez voir ça non je
vais essayer de le mettre sur un autre
sur un autre écran on va faire ça et ça
et je vais vous le montrer peut-être
2700 ch en rapide
on rapide qu'est-ce que ça donne
fais attention à pas et regardez Maxime
Achille la grave
on met des pubs alors j'ai des pubs de
partout alors Maxime va chez lagraphe
qui est numéro 4 mondial
ce qu'on peut voir ça rapidement
ah c'est dangereux c'est captures
d'écran
je sais je sais que c'est dangereux bon
ça marche je crois que je peux
je peux quand même je vais zapper vite
fait
sur le classement mondial
le classement mondial
on va faire ça
on va faire
hop là ah non je sais pas ce que je
voulais faire du tout n'importe quoi
et par contre le board hop là
regardez-moi ça on va faire
2700 chess
et promo là on propose des promos des
proviseurs Abritel et Nike on a connu
pire alors
on voit Maxime Vacher La Grave plus 16,9
numéro 4 mondial aussi simple que ça à
0,1 de dudat
c'est à dire qu'il est pas loin
dingueren numéro un mondial avec 2830 et
numéro 2 numéro 4 est-ce que en blitz il
y a une place à aller chercher il est où
Maxime oh il est très bas là
il est très très bas notre imaxime il
est à
2740 il va falloir corriger tout ça
c'est pas du tout son niveau 2740 en
blitz
mais à l'IRISA est dur à aller chercher
à 1896 manuscrit mondial simplement en
partie classique
ok ok
ce qu'on va faire c'est qu'on va revenir
sur ça et on a
on a ça et sur l'autre je sais pas faire
de bêtises non je crois que c'est bon je
crois que c'est bon mais c'est pas sûr
on verra tout ça
alors
Maxime ma chère on va voir il va
s'installer quelques il est ça c'est
Prague qu'on ira peut-être voir en cas
de nul rapide on ira voir
avec des bons joueurs on voit Raja bof
et mvl
permet d'avoir une place aux candidats
et ça va se jouer entre
IKA una caméra ca2780 et à zafirojack à
277 sachant que ça sera le meilleur
hello au mois de janvier
s'il y a deux trois points d'écart
encore au 20 décembre ça peut donner des
trucs bizarres
ça peut donner un Nakamura qui va à Las
Vegas joue un tournoi de partie
classique un allié resa qui va jouer
l'Open de Noël de de je sais pas où
ça peut être ça peut être marrant
on verra tout ça mais pour l'instant on
est concentré sur Maxime et sur ce boost
de confiance qui se donne en gagnant ce
tournoi de partir rapide avec une ronde
d'avance il a été quand même assez
incroyable
allez raisin je suis là s'il y a besoin
de quelques points l'eau sur la fin
c'est un petit match c'est un petit
match à Paris
et attention
il faut me battre
pourquoi pas un petit match on va voir
on va voir on va se battre il y a des
points à prendre effectivement
ça sera pas cadeau voilà exactement
attention ça sera pas cadeau je donnerai
tout
bon
après avec un tel Hello
qui fasse quoi les raisins avec son
hello 70% de moi bon c'est faisable
honnêtement
on verra tout ça on espère qu'on en sera
pas arrivé là mais c'est le risque avec
ce truc du vélo c'est le gros risque qui
est deux joueurs qui tiennent à quelques
points et que sur la fin il joue
ça peut ça peut faire ça alors est-ce
que on va avoir ouh là c'est 4 6 OK
étonnant
qu'est-ce qu'il va qu'est-ce qui va
faire qu'est-ce-que BD7 ok ok un grand
vide un mecs pourquoi pas
moi aussi j'ai créé une grosse sur la
gonfelder mais on a un gars très solide
intéressant de la part de Maxime
intéressant c'est ce que je joue en live
moi souvent ce gamin dans les califes
dans les califes du champion j'ai
beaucoup joué ça
c'est du solide
oui ils peuvent se faire un match sinon
mais bon je sais pas on verra qui est
bête donc là énormément de ligne c'est
prendre des 5 étant une des
plus solides on va une structure carsbad
avec C6 des 5 et e3d4 d'abord on va
sortir ce fou gentiment alors soit en G5
son F4
après il faut F4 on va voir si Maxime
improvise ou pas après il faut F4 parce
que ici le coup est pas évident à
deviner
le meilleur coup ici enfin le coup le
plus joué et cavalier B6
pour faire fout des 6 en un coup
donc c'est pas complètement intuitif il
faut que j'ai 5 jouets ok là on va voir
droit c'est 6 certainement le pion est
plus ou moins en prise et proposition de
nul
on a le droit de proposer nul
accepter
par Maxime machinagrave ok bon ben il y
a pas de raison de refuser il a gagné
bravo Maxime on l'applaudit sur 9 c'est
quand même beau on l'applaudit on va
voir une autre partie qu'est-ce qu'on va
voir comment
alors on a Prague contre
on a
Abdou Sator
qu'est-ce que vous préférez
quand même ça peut être sympa
est-ce que qui est 3e j'ai oublié déjà
qui peut rattraper un petit peu un
goûter je peux rattraper on va aller
voir Google alors du coup
alors voir notre ami Google
pour avant de se chauffer pour ceux qui
partent ne partez pas déjà et demain tu
auras de Blitz
avec
Maxime va chez La Grave à partir de
11h30
donc
vainqueur
vainqueur mvl 7 sur 9 c'est énorme c'est
juste énorme
c'est juste un tournoi un sans faute
pour Maxime Vacher la grave cette sur 9
voilà on si simple que ça
un cœur rapide
il a gagné il a gagné
clairement
plus 5
alors bon ça cette partie va être
ennuyeux c'est ça que vous êtes en train
de me dire
c'est possible
on veut gris de
ma voix qui compte plus quand même
alors est-ce qu'il y a une partie
marrante ça sur mon téléphone parce que
sinon après je fais des changements pour
pour pas grand chose
et
on va voir on va voir tout ça une partie
marrante une partie rigolote on a envie
de rire
c'est que le début donc on peut pas trop
deviner
pragueil
on aime la chaveningue
est-ce qu'on aime la chaveningue l'autre
c'est une ah tu es intéressante
ça m'intéresse
visite votez 1 est-ce que je peux faire
un
Robin site est toujours là
je peux pas là je suis pas connecté avec
mon pseudo de modo
alors B3 fou B2 c'était une sorte de
Meran mais il met pas le pur en D4 pour
laisser la grande diagonale ouverte pour
le fou en inconvénient c'est que les
Noirs vont pouvoir jouer E5 à un moment
normalement
mais il le fait pas il fait faire B6
pouvait cette d'abord sur pion prend il
y avait kéb5 était très embêtant mais
sur eux prend il fait quel prend des
cinq Vinson gamer avec l'idée sur ses
points des 5 dames et 6 on attaque le
four on attaque la tour
mesdames et cette dame prend à 8 on va
faire une qualité mais petit rock
attention cette dame et dans le dur elle
est dans le bureau à 8 intéressant
revenir
mais il y avait pas eu jusque-là
bon
c'est leur choix c'est une proposition
qui a été acceptée par par Maxime
je crois pas que il y a pas de raison de
refuser à part s'il y a une inimitié
particulière de Maxime envers rajabov
maxime est en quand même gentil garçon
dans le milieu il a pas d'ennemis
il y a pas d'ennemis quoi enfin vraiment
sachez que Maxime il faut quand même en
faire beaucoup
une seule personne a réussi on n'ira pas
on n'ira pas son nom
je crois à ma connaissance
il y a une seule personne mais qui est
pas un joueur du top
pas de
j'en connais qu'une c'est qui vas-y
balance
un tricheur un an non
on veut le nom on veut des infos le
peuple de savoir alors je dis je donne
un indice
ah oui ah il y a ça peut-être aussi mais
pas vraiment non il y en a un ah oui
peut-être deux ah oui finalement
ah oui ça balance dans le chat
un ancien président de fédé qui a réussi
quand même à se fâcher aussi
pas qu'un peu
mais alors lui vraiment pour le coup
finalement il est pas si gentil que ça
je sais pas si gentil que ça finalement
non non il est vraiment adorable et ceux
qui l'ont croisé le savent
ceux qui l'ont croisé le savent que
Maxime c'est vraiment quelqu'un qui
donne du temps aux fans et qui discutent
gentiment et voilà qui est vraiment très
très apprécié une fois qu'on l'a
rencontré mais j'ai balancé l'indice
ancien président de la fédé bon
française des échecs c'est pas très
compliqué quand même
mais voilà qui est quand même
globalement très respecté et très
apprécié par ces par ses collègues
voilà
vite petit rock
et maintenant qu'est-ce qu'on va faire
on va essayer d'en fermer cette dame
avec fou B7 et tout à 8 et c'est bizarre
de pas connaître de la part de gamer
tour c'est un peut-être il va falloir
faire quelque chose rapidement la jauge
est pas inquiète pour les blancs
mais franchement je suis plus inquiet
que ça
parce que
parce que parce que
parce que après tour C1 qui a validé ses
5 du coup et vous B7 qui arrive et tour
à 8 et on ramasse
non ratez
mauvaise devinette mais bon voilà en
gros
en gros
en gros ouais maxime est juste avec pas
de raison de refuser cette nul
c'est plutôt Raja bof qui devait jouer
dans ce cas précis
mais voilà il a décidé de pas le faire
pour assurer la deuxième place pour pas
jouer aussi c'est quand même risqué une
partie contre Maxime dans le quartier
dans cette forme ton sein il a fait
pousser cinq ou cacher connaître mais
apparemment c'est pas le bon coup
d'après la jauge mais après il a
certainement une jauge à la maison qui
est meilleure que celle là
ça troll pas mal sur twitch là j'ai
lancé un sujet où ça troll
j'ai vu un message marrant là sur
je suis bloqué
je suis bloqué par youtubeur français je
suis bloqué j'ai jamais parlé de ma vie
je crois pas je m'en souviens pas en
tout cas
c'est bizarre
mais bon B4
c'est pas très grave
ah non
ah oui pauvre de moi je suis tellement
gentil en plus franchement
alors dame français tour à huit dame
prend à 8 vous prend à 8 et ça leur
décompte bientôt c'est bien pour les
blancs
oui ce que je veux dire
voilà ce genre de truc ça plairait je
suis sûr
effectivement j'ai participé à la big up
c'était très bien d'ailleurs il faisait
chaud il fait chaud mais c'est pas c'est
vraiment sympa il fait chaud il fait
chaud en été à Paris vous voyez donc
dans une salle fermée il fait très chaud
sous les projecteurs il fait encore plus
chaud mais effectivement belle
expérience de jeu très sympa ce côté
ce côté
on joue sur ordi mais on est dans la
même salle belle pièce dans une avec des
ordis donc un beau concept clairement
effective
elle a bien joué elle a été elle a été
tenace elle s'est bien défendue et puis
quand elle a eu sa chance elle est bien
elle m'a elle m'a bien battu
j'étais parce que j'ai battu Baki
d'abord
et après tout le monde était évidemment
pour Alexandre même moi un petit peu au
fond de moi j'étais un petit peu pour
Alexandre c'est pour vous dire bon je
dis quand même pour moi globalement mais
voilà c'est sympa on est tellement sympa
et elle a battu elle a gagné cette big
up en battant
en battant
son mari
en finale
alors
faut deux ouais et puis de voir les
joueurs ouais je suppose que c'est sympa
aussi pour vous
les parties étaient étaient sympas et de
voir les joueurs en direct c'est quand
même plus sympa que derrière l'écran
clairement on va faire ça après c'est
pas possible de le faire chaque semaine
je sais pas je suppose que non mais de
faire ça tant en temps évidemment ça
rend le truc
vraiment unique et une belle expérience
de jeu
à refaire évidemment
alors faute d'eux H6 maintenant jouer
mais moi j'ai l'impression que les
blancs sont les écrasant j'ai
l'impression qu'il a fait n'importe quoi
Google mais à toute Blade alors est-ce
que je me trompe parce que le compte est
pas bon pour lui le compte est mauvais
là on a la dame on a la dame certes mais
il y a deux tours et pions alors il faut
empêcher qu'il y ait une attaque comme
ça mais franchement ça a l'air on a peur
de fou aussi je sais pas même un petit
coup de H3 pour empêcher kg mais
certainement petit rock un petit rock ça
va pas l'air
pas l'air qui est G4 ok ben 20 ans oust
par
petit rock et attention il y a le pion
là qui peut partir
le compte n'est pas bon comme on dit
dans une autre émission
l'émotion du petit French Fighter après
sa victoire contre Fabrice c'est vrai
que ouais mon Fab il avait envie de
commenter
il n'aime pas jouer il n'aime pas jouer
Fabi préfère commencer
pourquoi j'ai la jambe qui bouge parce
que je bouge malheureusement
alors faut deux H6 a été joué et
réfléchit Vincent il m'a l'air
complètement gagnant ça serait ça serait
pas mal de terminer sur une victoire je
vais ouvrir la fenêtre je reviens
en tout cas pour ceux qui nous
rejoignent vous le voyez en bas
vainqueur du rapide mvl 7 sur 9 de main
le Blitz et sachant que mvl est quand
même le champion du monde de blise 2021
et bien vu la forme qui tient ça sent
bon on va vibrer avec lui mais attention
attention cette jeune génération n'est
pas
n'est pas
n'est pas dépourvu de talent et donc ça
sera très très chaud avec Abdou satorov
cookeh praganenda
il m'en Sarine c'est dommage de pas voir
ça de Blitz
mais vidi to gamer et
le requin gritchouk qui a été aussi je
crois trois fois champion du monde de
Blitz alors attention
ça sera vraiment
quelque chose à suivre de près et on
suivra ça
de très près
il y a de toi avec une nulle non il
avait déjà gagné le tournoi donc en fait
même si il perdait donc c'était
indépendant du résultat de la dernière
donc il fait nuit avec Raja bof
parce qu'il y a pas de raison de refuser
sauf c'est ce que j'expliquais c'est
pour ça qu'on en est arrivé là cette
histoire d'inimitié s'il y a une amitié
particulière par exemple si je joue le
type du BTP
en face là
à la dernière rang de toi que j'ai déjà
gagné je la joue à fond voilà parce que
j'ai une limitée particulière avec lui
même si c'est pas de sa faute lui fait
juste son boulot mais quand même
donc voilà l'idée du truc
ouais ouais la partie je vous l'avais
dit hier ah non c'est quand même la
partie camp de visite a complètement
renversé le tournage je lui ai dit ça
peut être ça peut être vraiment
ça peut être vraiment un changement de
un déclic quoi voilà petit coup de bol
et il se remet dedans et le lendemain ça
y est quoi il a joué en mode
franchement là les deux derniers jours
c'est du c'est le carcène des bonjour
C'est voilà il a joué en mode Carlson
des bonjour sur les deux dernières
journées il a été extrêmement bon
extrêmement concentré utilisant son
temps à bon escient vraiment incroyable
alors on a en discute un peu en plus
c'est sympa si je joue une époque je la
joue à fond faut pas lui dire parce que
c'est lui qui peut me la jouer à fond si
si voilà
qui gagne un tournoi un gros tournoi
over the board tous les ans quand même
mais oui c'est ça c'est ça aussi Maxime
ça fait plaisir
et c'est encore une ligne de plus sur
son sur son déjà
très
glorieux palmarès
Samir Laurent qui me demande est-ce que
ton manque d'absence d'empathie
t'empêcher d'un thème de Top 10
stream et catchev en parler à propos des
champions du monde qui te dit que je que
j'ai de l'empathie déjà
non je sais pas franchement je crois que
c'est plus faut vraiment je sais pas je
sais pas
pas maintenant c'est je crois pas qu'il
y ait une seule raison en général de
toute façon pour les échecs ou pour les
pour les succès je crois qu'il y a c'est
toujours un cumulé on a une petite
accumulation de raison qui fait que on
est champion ou pas petit rock jouait je
suis pas du tout la partie la D4 et H3
jouer par gamer qui a l'air très très
bien cette partie on aurait peut être
depuis tout à l'heure pourquoi il a pas
pris
ah il a pas pris parce qu'il y avait des
dameset
normalement ça marche pas ce genre de
truc et surtout prends il y a quoi que
j'ai 4 il serait pas pour le bit de
demain et j'ai 4 menaces
beaucoup de choses ou la façade en
menace vous prend F3 je vous prends et
d'un proche-2 chez kebab
mais ordinateur pas inquiet pourquoi à
cause de G3 certainement mais j'ai trois
c'est pas un coup qu'on a envie de jouer
donc gamer il a dit ok ok ok fais-moi
tes histoires je te fais H3
oui de toute façon il y a que 10
personnes c'est aussi ça le problème en
fait
c'est ça le problème c'est qu'il y a un
Cody c'est il y a quand même beaucoup de
très bons joueurs qui passent beaucoup
de temps et beaucoup de talents donc
c'est un peu ça le problème
ok 2750 + ouais je sais pas je sais pas
honnêtement
si j'avais une réponse très claire à ta
portée j'aurais probablement été ou
alors à moins que ce soit le talent
on va pas parler du PSG là quand même
parce que moi je sens bien la saison
mais le problème c'est que toutes les
saisons je les sens bien
donc j'ai un peu tort à la fin c'est ça
le problème
alors ça va pas du tout en général sont
des 1 a été assez chanceux alors
chanceux j'aime pas dire ça mais c'est
vrai qu'il était en difficulté il était
perdant un moment qu'on me Prague il
était complètement perdant qu'on lui
dites donc effectivement il savait bien
sorti et cela a donné un boost il s'est
mis dedans et il a très très bien joué
après
je continue à bosser pour Magnus ici j'y
joue plus de toi de partie longue hein
donc c'est non compliqué si il se remet
à jouer des matchs peut-être
en bons termes
oh là là on est en mauvais termes avec
le camion qui passe dessous c'est pas
possible il faut un total aujourd'hui
moi qui habite dans une petite rue de
Paris où je me suis installé exprès pour
que il est pas voiture qui passe
tu as déménagé alors lui ou quoi ben non
j'ai pas déménagé le chat tu la connais
cette rue elle est toute petite il y a
personne personne ne passe depuis trois
jours je sais pas les travaux il y a 18
camions qui passent par jour pas par
jour par heure je comprends pas
non plus que les manifs on se rend
complet
et aussi je joue la fenêtre parce qu'il
fait il fait chaud
alors H3 jouer par gamer qui est très
très bien dans cette partie
ça existe pas des team pour faire des
petites prépas tricks pour du rapide de
bus ici bien sûr bien sûr que les
joueurs se préparent ça c'est évident
mais il y a besoin de moins de moins
préparé
mais bon je jouais aussi la Coupe du
Monde c'est un peu le problème
puis je joue très peu en vrai je joue
très peu donc
et en plus bon il l'a dit
il l'a dit
Magnus Carlsen il a plus envie de jouer
de partie classique
mais je pense que il va tenir sa parole
je pense qu'il va très très peu jouer en
particulier
c'est ça mais il le fait pas
mais est-ce qu'au final c'est partir 25
+ 10 ça sent pas plus sympa à suivre que
les parties classiques moi je trouve que
si
qui regarde les parties classiques en
entier et franchement
dites-moi voilà dans le chat
que ce
qui ont déjà regardé une partie
classique en entier c'est-à-dire du
début à la fin allez on a droit à 5
minutes de pause pour faire des
petits trucs mais voilà tu regardes
vraiment particules
oui en bossant à côté mais en faisant
que ça
en faisant que ça en regardant l'écran
en faisant que ça en est un focus et
tout ça qui a déjà fait ça même moi je
l'ai jamais fait
soit torture oui une fois alors que
franchement c'est parti rapide
tout le monde a déjà regardé une partie
rapide de A à Z parce que voilà on se
laisse prendre un truc à faire puis
finalement un peu moins puis on se dit
oh c'est quand même pas mal et puis
voilà partie est terminée
ça n'existe pas en fait personne ne
regarde les parties classiques en entier
donc je crois que c'est l'heure de
changer quand même
personne
que ceux qui ne font pas sorte non au
contraire qu'il reste vu que c'est du
vu que c'est du
c'est des rapides
il y a des belles parties pas tous les
jours d'ailleurs
mais je suis d'accord les parties
à mon avis les parties classiques
doivent continuer à exister pour les
amateurs
parce que justement c'est compliqué les
échecs et donc
il faut du temps ça les amateurs le
disent il faut du temps pour jouer c'est
parti mais je crois qu'à au niveau
ça ne doit plus ou de moins en moins
existé
on a dit
ouais c'est vrai mais
c'est vrai c'est vrai la sixième ouais
mais on me sort toujours un petit truc
ouais alors évidemment la 6e la 12e
entre Carlson et karwana effectivement
la sixième Magnus n'est pas c'est sûr
mais ça arrive
trop rarement
et je suis pas sûr que s'il y avait eu
un match de rapide avec quatre parties
par jour moi je pense que ça aurait
mieux marché
mon avis
et oui
ouais bah elle est déjà en train de se
faire la transition vers le rapides au
niveau regardez où il joue là il joue ça
champion de chaise tour avant
c'est quand même en train je trouve il y
a de plus en plus c'est quand même la
tendance
et même quand c'est toi de partie
classique genre on achète ils arrivent à
mettre un Armageddon derrière et même
quand c'est la Coupe du Monde ou c'est
parti classique il y a des rapides
derrière en départage et tout ça il y a
toujours du rapide
je veux bien j'ai joué j'ai joué
j'ai joué quand même un champion de
France j'ai commencé en je vais pas le
dire je pensais à 98
je vous fais un historique j'ai joué le
National depuis 1998 j'ai dû rater allez
4 ou 5
les gens quand ils viennent me voir très
fort sympathiquement qui viennent me
parler il me parle que de mes matchs de
les partages il ne se souviennent pas
d'une partie longue
donc les souvenirs qui se sont créés
sont que des matchs de les partages
alors pour les moins jeunes
c'est le match de départage à Besançon
en 99 avec Bacro
pour les plus jeunes c'est celui de 2017
avec l'Armageddon et compagnie mais bon
bref
que de matchs pas une seule fois on va
parler de d'une partie langue quelque
chose comme ça
donc on crée les souvenirs chez les
spectateurs grâce à ces assez parti
rapide sauf
pour des trucs exceptionnels
exceptionnel
comme le disaitiocha n'est pas Carlsen
quand ça dure 8 heures quand il y a un
truc
fantastique qui se passe bon c'est le
record c'est la partie la plus longue de
l'histoire des championnats du monde où
ça se termine le lendemain
du début de la partie en fait bon
incroyable
d'accord
mais les gens voilà ils viennent parler
de ça alors après
dans le même
niveau quoi mais peut-être il y a les
joueurs et les joueuses un peu plus
forts qui se souviennent un peu plus des
parties à cadence classique mais dans
les côtés amateurs qui jouent les open
aucune chance
bon en tout cas on verra c'est le choix
évidemment des organisateurs et on voit
ce pour être plus grand plaisir on a ce
tournoi de partir rapide
mais c'est parce que tu étais pas en 99
c'est pour ça que tu te souviens pas de
mon match contre contre
il a toujours regardé il a une très très
belle position Vincent gamer
foin qui est des cinq tours 3D 3 et d'un
massette mais c'est dis donc il a été il
a été beaucoup dans le bureau dans ce
tournoi Google
mais franchement il se bat bien
il va bien
il va bien parce qu'il a pas encore
ridicule
et même il est même troisième il est
loin d'être ridicule mais alors
qu'est-ce qu'il a été dans le dur dans
ce tournoi et là encore une fois il est
complètement foutu au sortir de
l'ouverture hein juste pour dire vous
c'est 4 ça joue tout seul avec les
Blancs
ouais bah ça c'est pas c'est pas un
argument
oui mais ça il faut empêcher les
propositions il y a plus de nuls
c'est pas parce que c'est pas à cause de
la formule la plus de nul c'est à cause
de la
c'est à cause de cette il faut faire une
interaction proposée évidemment que
c'est enfant
là elle dure qu'une heure donc là c'est
pas assez croyez-moi vous mettez 30
coups comme à la Coupe du Monde Coupe du
Monde vous voyez il y a pas eu beaucoup
de nuls pourquoi
il est beaucoup plus si on n'avait pas
interdit les propositions de nulles
avant le 30e coup ce qui est la règle à
la Coupe du monde si vous faites ça au
championnat de France vous inquiétez pas
vous allez pas avoir beaucoup de
ouais dit doli tout à fait tu veux pas
retrouver le couteau dans la plaie je me
souviens plus ce qui s'est passé en 99
la journée s'est fabuleux oui maintenant
c'est un peu plus exister avec les ordis
tourner par Vincent gamer il est très
très bien regardez c'est de Tours qu'il
faut un job magnifique c'est de fou qui
font un job magnifique
cette dame qui a peut-être prendre un
pion quoi que là on peut pas vraiment le
prendre j'ai l'impression hein c'est 4
ça fait quand même mal
c'est la mauvaise surprise en fait une
surprise c'est pas vraiment
espérer dans ma 3 peut-être pour faire
pression sur ça même là je peux m'amuser
à faire de la tactique non je sais pas
je m'amuse pas je m'amuse ou pas
je voulais faire [__] et où là prends
G7 reprend G7 et tour 1 mais il y aura
du Mb4 qui m'embête un petit peu
je fais ce que je veux ici les cavaliers
sont complètement dominés je peux même
faire tomber un et c'est archi gagnant
en fait c'est juste trop facile une
position ouverte comme ça avec la paire
de fou et les tours franchement c'est
quand même terminé
alors la proposition de cramique c'est
de jouer sans rock moi je crois pas je
crois que le jeu est suffisamment
compliqué
pour pour qu'on continue à jouer avec
ses règles comme ça c'est comme le
chasso 160
honnêtement
déjà pour moi c'est dur à suivre je sais
que les gens le retour des gens c'est
que c'est compliqué qu'on comprenait
rien
donc je suis assez d'accord avec ça
alors le tournoi a lieu en Inde tout à
fait à Calcutta c'est marqué juste au
dessus de moi
qu'est-ce qu'il fait Google
il est mal
il est très mal
on marque ça arrangerait certains
joueurs ou joueuses cette absence de
d'avoir le droit de roquer
qui passe souvent
pas assez souvent
son rock à la mer
il y a pas du tout arrêté ses échecs
Damas 3
Google
qu'est-ce qu'il fait alors
on voit plus trop bon on va trop le voir
je sens il était à la Coupe du monde
il était à la Coupe du monde et pas
longtemps
non non il joue il joue beaucoup hein
champion des je crois qu'il a gagné le
championnat des Pays-Bas récemment il
jouait le champion de gestion en
division 3 la semaine dernière
donc non non il joue quel coup le
meilleur coup là il a joué fou 5 ouais
j'ai proposé il faut 5 c'est mort
j'y pensais justement je me disais que
ça menacait aussi tour un et sur
cavalier prank et prend on mettait la
pression sur le pur F7
division 3 c'est pas évident de se
qualifier dans ce plan
ski en Division 3
le retour de Gata
en menace qui peut gagner la partie sur
le champ
il prend l'eau
il prend le goût caisse incroyable qui
l'autre ex aequo
a c'est quelque chose
ensuite voir s'il a une chance de gagner
la personne
ce qui me rend fou c'est qui coupe
toujours la même plan je comprends pas
je vais fermer
je vous jure je vous jure je vous jure
que le type coupe encore la même planche
j'ai envie de prendre une photo quoi de
la mettre sur Twitter
je comprends pas je sais pas ce qu'il
fait
incroyable
alors
qu'est-ce qu'il a joué sur faut 5 ben il
réfléchit mais en même temps
pas fait cher longtemps on menace on
menace Toutain tu auras un tour prend un
vide c'est méga bingo si on prend ici on
reprend attention on peut plus sortir ce
cavalier parce qu'il y a le pion FC en
complètement et pareil le problème sur
MBK c'est qu'on perd une pièce comme ça
et c'est aussi fini incroyable cette
ouverture de Google qui s'est avait
l'air correct mais il s'est complètement
trompé
c'est dingue
c'est complètement dingue
très décevant
pour moi en tout cas ce que j'ai
beaucoup d'estime pour pour Google
vraiment je le vois vraiment comme un
potentiel futur champion du monde mais
là des parties il fait des parties
je sais pas c'est quand même incroyable
ce qui se passe si 25 + 10 il s'affolent
au bout de 3 minutes il est foutu
bon
il y a pas de
quoi il s'est fait ouvrir dans
l'ouverture non en fait pas vraiment
parce qu'en fait c'est lui qui menait le
bal quand même il jouait très vite
donc c'est quand même c'est quand même
bizarre cette histoire
il joue très vite et puis quand il
commence à réfléchir il est complètement
foutu là il peut
proposer nul
donc
a bien fait de
il sera deuxième il reste encore Prague
et easy cette rollingen
et ados à
joue
mais on va rester sur cette partie avec
Google cash qui est le seul attention
oui parce que Google c'est hyper du coup
il peut il est même pas 3e
et joue kb6 en vissant la pièce OK
ok
il fait quoi
Mb4 pas trop de coup et maintenant si je
fais tourner
c'est l'air pas mal quand même tout ça
si cavalier prend j'ai tout reprend à 8
le 10 est bon pour moi
F3 semble être le coup mais là un petit
échec ou pardon ouh là là je fais
n'importe quoi
je vais vous montrer ça pardon pardon
pardon pardon pardon j'ai fait je me
suis emballé là
je me suis complètement emballé
regardez je vous montre donc
on est de retour
pour prendre des 7
j'ai le mauvais live
pour prendre des sets et sur foo.fr
qui tient donc apparemment le coup de la
jauge c'est vous prend un FC toi
et non seulement un animateur en plus
mais on attaque de maths ça va pas
ouais
j'ai l'impression en faisant ça
c'est son choix toi
une tactique très simple pour un joueur
du niveau de gamer
un peu plus de temps mais ça va gagner
aussi
fini
on va voir quel ordre laquelle il
préfère
quelle variante il préfère
qu'elle variante il va choisir je sais
pas j'ai l'impression que
ouais je sais pas on reprend des 7 quand
même sacrément efficace
alors sur cavalier prend allez sur quel
il prend cette fois il y a bien bel et
bien maths
on le monte parce que c'est joli
et c'est terminé
c'est complètement terminé va-t-il voir
tout reprendre et 7 je pense que oui si
on va pas te reprendre les 7 gamer il
est mal pour le bide moi je vous le dis
on donne pas cher de sa peau pour le
Blitz s'il voit pas tout reprendre et 7
parce que ça se voit ça se voit facile
et je me mets en VIP ça y est je fatigue
allez hop on s'assoit ici et ensuite ça
on suit ça au premier rang en Amérique
mon ticket reprends à 8
et tu reprends des 7
ok
c'est dingue quand même franchement
l'autre était mieux je trouve bon
le manque de confiance parfois ça fait
faire des choix comme ça il est obligé
avec sa gamin de d'essayer de faire
quelque chose il y a un seul point
faible dans le cas
des blancs c'est le pur F2
il le sait gamer il le regarde il sait
qu'il est complètement gagnant on peut
faire un petit coup de fougère
ce pion d'abord et ensuite on va
s'occuper de celui là en combinaison
avec ça peut-être un cavalier l'arbre
cavalier là en fonction de comment les
Noirs s'organisent
alors tour à 7
bien joué Michael 87 1987
superbe super superbe contre-attaque
mais il y a pas besoin de ça on peut
faire fouger 3 allez faut trois
gentiment
gentiment d'abord protège nos pions
apprendre à des autres
ouais ciel bleu tu reprends à 8 et tu
reprends les 7 et équivalent en fait je
crois que c'est vraiment facilement
gagnant faut juste s'organiser sur le
plan F2
je crois que j'ai trois
jouets C4
il est obligé de faire ces quatre sinon
oui il fait ses quatre dans ces 7
et maintenant
c'est intenable
intenable
comment on fait ces trois mais il faut
encore le prendre ce pion
c'est pour ça que je préfère l'autre
parce qu'effectivement si on fait
cailler des cadres B2 je sais pas je
touche pas mais comment j'avance c'est
pas si évident en fait
c'est gagnant c'est il y a pas de il y a
pas de souci là-dessus mais quand même
voir ce qu'il va faire ton C7 jouer C3
jouer alors là on peut faire fausse 5 et
transposer dans cette finale qui doit
être complètement gagnant aussi un homme
prend F2 tours
quelque chose comme ça
mais on a ouvert un petit peu le roi et
perpettes on sait jamais
attention c'est un diable
notre ami Google
défenseur hors pair
il a fait beaucoup de sauvetage dans ce
tournoi
peut-être un de plus
on va voir
n'oubliez pas demain
c'est pas terminé certes
Maxime et le vainqueur des rapides mais
de manière et Blitz et ça va être très
sympa c'est du 3 + 2 demain les Blitz
alors là ça va donner ça va être vu du
dessus public tout le temps
on va faire que cette vue parce que 3 +
2 on a vraiment pas le temps
ça va être beau il va y avoir des
retournements de situation je vous
raconte pas il va nous faire des tours
de magie mvl ça va être toute la journée
ça va être beau on a hâte on a hâte
parce qu'il est il est triquillant
il a quand même beaucoup beaucoup de
ressources ah ouais une belle favori
maintenant la belle favoris
parce que déjà c'était pas clair qui est
meilleur que lui
dans le tournoi
et maintenant il a la forme qui tient
bah oui oui
confiance
et bravo à Maxime qui était énorme
alors comment il fait la miegamer plus
que 6 minutes pour décider de est-ce
qu'on se débarrasse de ce pion c'est
est-ce qu'on le garde pour plus tard et
il fait il joue feu 5 et d'un prime F2
blitzer 3
mais il sait créer des problèmes
techniques
ça va être gagnant
ouais mais
dangereux après il a montré des
gambinets acceptés je pense que il
jouait des quatre dessins donc il
voulait jouer a priori et Damas de jouer
bon il y a pas grand chose à faire pour
les Noirs clairement il y a pas de
faiblesse à côté blanc c'est quand même
le principe toutes les pièces voyez si
je mets la tour protège le pion le Fou
est protégé par le cavalier le pion
Jessie le pion protège ici le roi est en
sécurité et la tour est protégée par le
fou donc vous voyez il y a aucune
faiblesse bon maintenant il faut
attaquer quelque chose
je me remonte un peu
je m'affole sur le canapé je m'affole
sur mon siège je suis bien sur mon siège
franchement
non honnêtement
honnêtement là je suis bien comme aussi
il peut tourner en rond avec sa dame ça
change pas grand chose
oui exactement romain Huet c'est un bon
argument George Couton je sais pas qui
est George couteau j'ai pas lu son truc
mais je pense quand même que le regard
intérêt du public compense cette baisse
de niveau si tant elle
qu'elle soit même perceptive pour des
amateurs
je crois que c'est pas du tout alors là
je vous mets au défi
quand on a Maxime qui joue comme ça là
devinez c'est une partie longue ou une
partie rapide qui est capable de faire
ça moi je m'en sens pas capable
et oui
c'est ça aussi c'est qu'il y a pas de
différence
terme du niveau de jeu niveau de jeu
mais on est
pour ces joueurs là pour Magnus parfois
il joue mieux en 25 + 10 quand quand
deux heures 40 coups vous jouez même
coup de toute façon souvent
franchement même en partie là on joue au
bout d'une minute en général
pas toujours à on change d'avis
évidemment mais
quand même souvent on peut on peut jouer
le même coup
donc voilà donc pour le public c'est pas
du tout perdu perceptible donc en me
raconter l'histoire
alors que un film
au cinéma
bon là c'est perceptible pour le grand
public
c'est différent c'est pas comparable
non non je suis pas d'accord pour les
langues c'est pour les happy few c'est
de l'art
ça
il y a plus de prépa c'est tout ça
change quasiment rien
alors c'est un bon coup j'aime beaucoup
il veut faire le 5 et oui c'est bien
joué
5 je crois qu'il va il va finir sur une
bonne note gamer ça c'est un bon système
qu'il a trouvé
ok je peux toujours réfléchir
il est rincé dans cette partie
terminée pour lui
je le prends pas de même d'idées de
défense c'est ça le problème
j'ai l'impression que c'est calme d'or
je reviens
et non je suis pas d'accord avec vous
allez teraka qui dit les échecs n'ont
pas forcément vocation à être grand
public oui bon ben si quand même on a
envie de partager notre passion avec le
plus de monde possible en plus il se
trouve que en l'occurrence c'est aussi
mon métier donc oui j'ai plutôt envie
qu'il y a du monde qui joue et
effectivement
ne pas faire le truc dans mon coin
oui
puis même je pense que c'est un bon jeu
pour les gens pour les enfants en
particulier
voilà donc oui j'ai envie de qui est si
tu me demandes ce que j'ai envie de tous
les enfants aux échecs oui je pense que
c'est bien pour les enfants je pense que
ça apporte des qualités ça développe des
qualités qui sont qui sont très
importantes dans la vie en général
concentration la mémoire la prise de
décision le respect de l'adversaire
l'acceptation la défaite c'est important
ça on peut s'en prendre qu'à soi-même
quand on perd
la patience
voilà
c'est quand même un bon jeu plutôt que
des oui voilà c'est ça plutôt que les
jeux qu'on peut voir sur ordi où il faut
cliquer le plus de possible
prends réfléchir tout simplement
poser des questions à se remettre en
question aussi très important parce que
quand on perd
on peut pas on peut pas on peut pas
blâmer le voisin sauf si il fait de la
personne mais normalement on peut pas
visualisation dans l'espace très voilà
oui le Bullet effectivement on joue pas
Bullet
comme c'est une petite partie il y a une
partie psychologique aux échecs mais ça
c'est évident
aussi c'est un jeu quand même très
complet on a de la chance pour ça qu'on
va choisir aussi sans savoir mais sans
s'en rendre compte mais en fait ça quand
j'ai 8 E5 dames des cinq jouets mais
ouais ouais même le bleu la psychologie
est très importante la stratégie aussi
ce baser aussi et prendre des décisions
c'est quand même quelque chose où les
informations sont incomplètes où on peut
jamais calculer tout jusqu'au bout et
donc il y a un moment il faut se servir
son intuition et ça c'est c'est la vie
en fait c'est la vie qui fait ça on sait
pas quand on prend une décision dans la
vie sur son job sur ce qu'on veut bien
c'est l'information incomplète on sait
pas ce qui va se passer
et donc effectivement on doit baser ces
décisions sur l'intuition
et c'est pareil aux échecs on peut pas
tout calculer jusqu'au bout
et aussi
la psychologie donc notamment
l'adaptation la constante adaptation à
son adversaire
plutôt la nouvelle position à chaque
nouvelle position parce que chaque
position est différente
et donc c'est un jeu d'adaptation avant
tout et aussi à l'adversaire évidemment
ah moi je crois
je crois alors là la gadette qui dit moi
quelle mesure les choses qu'on apprend
dans un domaine on arrive effectivement
les transposer dans un autre
pour avoir bossé trois ans à 24 et fait
des réunions
souvent assez interminables les types
ils arrivent pas à prendre une décision
on reconnaît le joueur d'échec là dedans
et un moment faut jouer un coup
ça je te le garantis ça c'est déjà rien
que cette qualité là je l'ai vu alors je
peux prendre une décision elle peut être
mauvaise mais je prends une décision
quand même vraiment faut trancher
ça c'est enfin je sais pas ceux qui
travaillent en entreprise ici bon
il y a certainement beaucoup d'entre
vous qui font des réunions interminables
ils sont contents parce que finalement
ils peuvent jouer aux échecs pendant la
réunion c'est ça c'est ce que disait
j'ai vu ça sur Twitter combien de Blitz
je joue par jour ça dépend du nombre de
réunions que j'ai c'est un peu ça mais
voilà souvent il y a des quand même on
peut on peut tourner en rond dans ce
genre de réunion moi c'est c'est
impression que j'ai un V puisqu'on me
dit globalement
on peut mater mvl pendant la réunion
télétravail
alors tour des deux
et comment on va faire ça pas si simple
regardez-moi mon bouquet là comment il
se bat
ah ben moi j'avais pas des réunions qui
duraient 15 minutes je vous le garantis
mais effectivement
elle doit bouger ce qu'elle fait en F5
c'est pas mal ça
dit ou en cours une fois je me suis
chopé mais le prof a fait hésité parce
que c'est des échecs
alors comment on fait pour gagner cette
partie la faiblesse du camp des Noirs
c'est à mon avis le pion F7
et je crois qu'il est en train de
s'organiser pour leur D6 et ton F4
ensuite et on va attaquer deux fois ce
puret 7 et le manger quoi qu'il arrive
je crois que c'est quand même assez
terminé chez Google honnêtement ça va
être compliqué de la sauver celle-là
je vois pas en tout cas
il a quand même ah oui il fait ça quoi
ça c'est le desperados comme on en fait
plus
j'ai 5 et il revient F3
l'air sur de lui alors qu'est-ce qu'il
veut faire la tour en F6 c'est ça
il y a pas un qui est là
j'essaie donc là je pense qu'il va faire
tourner 6 tours F6 et voir et voir ce
qui se passe
est-ce qu'il fait ça
et il le fait
et toi F6 et attention on peut aller là
maintenant
ça va pas être simple
enfin c'est pas simple pour vous cacher
c'est très compliqué il peut rien faire
comment on joue ici je sais pas il y a
pas de il y a pas de bonne défense je
sais qu'il faut tenir la case des quatre
parce que si il faut mettre la dame par
là toi aussi sinon ça va être trop
simple si on laisse faire 5 donc
maintenant faut attendre par là quelque
chose comme ça
et il faut encore montrer au blanc les
blancs doivent encore prouver
ne d'avoir vu c'est marrant son body
lingue
indique qu'il a vu ça finit contre roi
je crois même pas
Fab the Fab
je voudrais me casse
alors maintenant comment il veut faire
c'est joli pour voir que les forteresses
n'existent pas
et réfléchis je pensais que le plan
était clair et ce qui veut pas faire ça
et H4 ensuite
alors ça ça
parce que mon idée c'est de forcer une
décision sur ce pion si on fait puis on
prend que les prend ensuite je vous caie
F5 et j'encaisse ici et j'encaisse ici
mais j'ai 4
et maintenant du coup comment on fait
pour ramener ce cavalier c'est ça la
grande question je n'en sais rien
pas si évident j'aime pas je casse
finalement
non je sais pas c'est pas si évident il
y avait la relax mais bon ok toi F6 ok
whatever très belle décoration la part
de notre ami allemand
alors Dame des cinq ouais
on peut pas comme j'ai déjà dit
plusieurs fois on peut rien attaquer
et donc on peut réattaquer avec la dame
donc il faut juste empêcher les menaces
là la grosse menace c'est évidemment de
faire mettre ce cavalier en F5
et comment on fait quel chemin
et bien je serais bien embêté avec les
Blancs
je sais pas comment je ferais
mais je suis pas le seul à être embêté
mais c'est marrant ça parce qu'il avait
l'air tellement relax c'est plutôt d'un
coup on voit il a l'air qui est
maintenant comme si il avait pas vu le
je sais pas c'est bizarre
non j'ai dit tout à l'heure que les à
mon avis les amateurs devaient jouer les
parties langues pas les professionnels
ah ok
il revient et maintenant il va faire que
des cadres mais après comment il fait
je sais pas comment il fait il y a eu un
résultat là-bas entre
Eric Gaye Yard June et on va essayer
d'aller voir ce qui s'est passé non ça
c'est pas eux
entre Arjun
et
Prague easy
est-ce qu'il reste encore une autre
partie
à part celle-là d'après jouer
oh là là
qu'est-ce qui rame qu'est-ce qui rame
c'est pas évident franchement
peut-être aussi c'est un moment ou un
autre
puis on prend
et cavalier 5 choses comme ça pour
récupérer le pion peut-être tour d'essai
se lancer une attaque de maths j'aime
bien aussi
comme ça on se casse plus la tête
alors admettons H5
pour menacer H4
est-ce que peut faire ça
3g8 j'espère une case malheureusement
on a on a autre chose et row F6
évidemment que j'ai quatre aussi mais il
y a rangé 8 donc ça ne va pas
ce qu'il est en train de calculer à mon
avis notre ami et
sur G4 il va faire cailler des quatre
maintenant
il fait
peut-être qu'il pousse maintenant
ça sert quand même complètement gagnant
H4 de toute façon il va le faire G4
parce qu'il a pas tellement le choix non
il a pris un et après il a décidé que
l'autre était complètement foutu bon
qu'avait les princes 4 va être joué a
priori
qui est joué
la MG5 tours
c'est à peu près certain
regardez-moi ça
comment il se débat
ce goût cache
et comme ça sur dommage 5 rois géant des
clouages mais échec
problème j'ai un
c'est jouer toi F6
alors qu'est-ce qu'il peut faire
je me décale
alors toi
et faire foi F4
sans qu'il échec
je crois que là les carottes sont cuites
il a joué vite
sur 4 il veut quoi
c'est pas
on va savoir
et maintenant le pervers
2 quoi
6 donc sur échec ils veulent là sur
échec il va aller là il se cache
il joue sur
prend un 6 on en est où là
et 4 sur ok ok ok
je fais un petit coup de refresh
de la partie après tu reprends H6
dans ma chambre
[Musique]
et dans le cas de jouer tout F6 et on a
une structure complètement imperméable
vous voyez où tout est protégé ou quasi
pas le cavalier mais bon
c'est quand même bien terminé cette
partie normalement la technique de
Vincent game
4 et il est là mais il va jouer F3 et
oui et maintenant on menace même je
crois des tours F7 si on reprend
donc là ça va être très très compliqué
il y a pas de perpète le roi est
beaucoup trop safe
faut que j'ai 5 il va faire tourrage 6
tour H4 et fof 6 et mater en fait
ouais il est relax Vincent parce que
c'est très facile
c'est honnêtement c'est il y a pas de
risque donc là il va jouer ton H6
évidemment
on ira voir de cette offerte chauffer
chez Abdou cette offre
pour pas être matte tout de suite
à quoi que non
aussi
parce qu'en fait
jouer
comment on fait maintenant tour H4 air
quand même très tentant
et maintenant il veut certainement foie
F6 un jour ou l'autre j'ai 6 jouer
c'est génial
c'est beau hein
c'est ça qui est très beau avec eux si
vous avez 4
puis joue pas des coups pour pas
abandonner et j'ouvre vraiment des coups
pour
pour essayer d'arnaquer tout simplement
ouais c'est normal de pas abandonner ça
va c'est rapide à 3000 chacun oui ça va
c'est pas scandaleux
et encore des perpettes il y a qu'à
montrer
après c'est totalement foutu ça c'est
sûr
je te rachis échec alors sur moi j'ai 7
il veut quoi ranger cette va être
quasiment à moins que à moins que à
moins que
veuille tanti de toute façon il est
tellement foutu que pourquoi pas
franchement
pourquoi pas
on va voir
ça dans le manque pas beaucoup d'impact
de toute façon sur le résultat de la
partie qui est assez clair depuis
longtemps
attention après échec on fait quoi parce
que
et on peut faire un tour on peut faire
un tour de manège
mais
c'est drôle mais ça fait rien
c'est mieux
alors héro F5
c'est pas mal quand même
bon pourquoi pas
d'être mon coup
rider quelque chose d'autre c'est sûr
c'est pas le seul coup et je crois bon
c'est la même chose et
à tempo ça crée
chaque jouet
regarde seul coup légal c'est ça la
différence entre coup illégal et
tous les autres coups étaient on m'a
demandé la définition tout à l'heure de
Queen légale
c'est ça ici trois quatre et le seul
coup légal de la position
des trois tours des cas trois C2
tellement foutu de toute façon
échec
quand cette chaud cette histoire
il va en C3 il cherchait tout pour pas
perdre tout de suite c'est ça le genre
pour vous cacher
il est pas sûr de lui il est pas
confiant
c'est assez étonnant
alors dans le 6 ou là
ça ça va donner des découvertes quand
même par exemple tour des six c'est 6
quoi que encore mais bon
la tour plus protégée
mais ça va tout va bien sur de la F5 on
a tout rêve de tout simplement et on a
assez échec après
je crois que les cordes sont cuites là
pour goûter
ça fait un moment mais bon
je crois que c'est fini là
c'est complètement fini
ah ouais mais
on n'aime pas la règle des 50 coups
d'accord mais il faut bien que ça
s'arrête à un moment quand même
il faut être gentil
B3
encore un coup tout F2 menace ton F3 6
tout ce qu'on a envie à faire bouger le
roi j'ai l'impression ici
mais bon et je crois ces quatre
pas prendre le pion on aimerait ton F3
jouer et j'ai l'impression qu'il y a
plus d'échecs par contre
donc il faut protéger le pion voilà dame
B7
jouer et maintenant le dernier coup de
massue
quel est-il pour encaisser ce pion
des 8 jouer par Vincent
F5 qu'est-ce que c'est que ce coup sur
pion prend en passant et la dame B8
c'est pour ça que l'autre était mieux
mais même dame mais ça doit gagner ah il
y a ton rêve 4 échec ah oui après en
passant évidemment
vous avez vu
le F7 là c'est intéressant quand même
il prend la dame
abandons de goûter chez victoire de
Vincent gamer est-ce qu'il nous reste
une partie ou pas
non et ça applaudit simplement
et félicitations à Maxime vacherer qui
s'impose dans ce tournoi finalement avec
un point et demi d'avance sur tes mots
Raja bof
trois execos la troisième place ah oui à
la faveur de victoire Prague et visite
on rattrapé gris chouk et donc ils ont 5
points Google qu'on vient de voir qui a
perdu quatre et demi 50% des points
assez décevant dans ce tournoi d'où ça
t'auras aussi un peu dans le dur 4
Vinson qui a gagné
3,5
dans le dur mais surtout la grande
nouvelle c'est Maxime Vacher La Grave
complètement impérial dans ce tournoi et
donc félicitations à lui
dès demain on se retrouve pour le
tournoi de Blitz qui commencera qui sera
sur deux jours on prend les mêmes on
recommence ça sera neuf ronde demain et
9 rondes après demain même joueur mais
couleur inversées
11h30 prise d'enterrer un petit peu
avant je vous remercie infiniment de
m'avoir suivi encore un énorme bravo à
mvl et je vous dis à demain pour la
suite ciao ciao
quel est le meilleur moyen de suivre
n'importe quel événement échiquier
surplus du monde au tournoi des
candidats en passant par le speechestre
ou les titles
il se déroulent en présentiel ou en
ligne vivez comprenez en direct les
parties des meilleurs joueurs de la
planète avec les commentaires en
français de nos experts notre moteur
d'analyse l'explorateur d'ouverture et
les tables bases retrouvez toutes les
infos essentielles comme le programme
les horaires des rondes les prix les